la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Noël
barraot ministre délégué chargé du
numérique bonjour madame la
présidente madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur général madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés l'insécurité que nos concitoyens
rencontrent sur Internet sappe leur
confiance dans la transition numérique
et tous les Français sont concernés par
les désordres en tout genre qui
s'accumulent dans l'espace numérique et
en particulier les Français les plus
vulnérables nos concitoyens les plus
âgés ou les plus éloignés du numérique
qui sont les proies privilégiés des
cybercriminels nos enfants qui sont
victimes en ligne d'atteinte brutale à
leur innocence nos entreprises que la
loi du plus fort place dans une
situation
d'assujétissement vis-à-vis des géants
du numérique et notre démocratie qui
subit les coups de boutoir incessant des
professionnels de la désinformation et
des ingénieurs du chaos face à cela
depuis 6 ans la France sous l'impulsion
du Président de la République a agi au
niveau national avec des lois visant la
désinformation la protection de
l'enfance en ligne au niveau européen
avec la construction d'un socle de
régulation de l'espace numérique
européen et au niveau international avec
des initiatives prises par le Président
de la République comme l'appel de Christ
Church ou le forum de Paris sur la paix
qui ont contribué à éveiller la
conscience mondiale sur ces sujets le
projet de loi qui vous ai proposé de
d'examiner poursuit le même objectif et
s'est formé à partir de trois affluents
le premier le premier affluent
c'est ce sont les deux règlements que la
France a porté et qui ont été adoptés au
niveau européen l'année dernière et que
nous devons pour qu'il puisse euh se
s'appliquer correctement adapt dans
notre droit français ces deux règlements
il mettent fin à une quinzaine d'années
pendant lesquelles les géants du
numérique se retranchaient derrière les
différences de nos législations
nationales au niveau européen pour fuir
toute forme de responsabilité c'est
d'abord le Règlement sur les service
numérique le DSA qui fait rentrer ces
grandes plateformes dans l'aair de la
responsabilité en exigeant d'elle
qu'elle partte leur donné avec les
chercheurs qu'elles fassent auditer
leurs algorithmes qu'ell s'abstiennent
de faire de la publicité ciblée sur les
mineurs et qu'ell tiennent compte et
corrigent le risque systémique qu'elles
font peser sur la santé de leurs
utilisateurs sur la qualité du débat
public ou encore sur la sécurité public
le deuxième règlement c'est le Règlement
sur les marchés numériques qui lui vient
mettre fin aux pratiques commerciales
déloyales qui ont permis à des géants du
numérique de s'octroyer des positions de
monopole sur certains marchés plaçant
les entreprises européennes les
collectivités les administrations et
même les particuliers dans un lien de
dépendance et empêchant les entreprises
européennes concurente d'entrer sur ces
marchés et c'est ainsi que ce règlement
sur les marchés numériques édicte 26
pratiques qui seront désormais interdite
dans les États-membres de l'Union
européenne la préinstallation d'un
navigateur d'un moteur de recherche ou
d'un assistant personnel sur un
smartphone l'autopréférence qui consiste
à
faire apparaître de manière plus
favorable ses propres services que ceux
de ses concurrents ou encore
l'utilisation des données collectées sur
l'un des services des proposé par une
entreprise pour faire de la publicité
sur un autre de ces services autant de
pratiques qui seront désormais
interdites le deuxième affluent ce sont
les travaux parlementaires qui ont été
menés à l'Assemblée comme au Sénat ces
six dernières années pour mieux protéger
nos concitoyens nos enfants nos
entreprises dans l'espace numérique je
pense aux travaux de beréranger
Couillard et de de Guillaume Gouffier
Vallante sur l'exposition des mineurs au
contenu pornographique poursuivi par
quatre sénatrices de tout bord qui ont
publié un excellent rapport sur le sujet
je pense au travaux de Bruno Studer ou
de Laurent Marcangeli sur la protection
de l'enfance en ligne aux travaux
d'Erwan balanan sur la question du
harcèlement à ceux de Philippe latombe
sur la question de la souveraineté
numérique dans le domaine de l' de de de
l'infonuagique ou encore ce plus récent
de Stéphane vogetta sur l'influence en
ligne le 3 3è affluent à partir duquel
ce projet de loi s'est formé ce sont les
consultations que nous avons mené sous
l'égide du Conseil national de la
refondation et en particulier sur la
question de la
pacification de l'espace numérique et au
final euh le le fil rouge de ce texte
qu' vous a proposé d'examiner c'est
celui de la protection de nos
concitoyens de nos enfants de nos
entreprises et collectivités dans
l'espace numérique au chapitre de la
protection de nos concitoyens d'abord
trois mesures importantes la première
c'est le filtre anti-arnac qui servira
de rempart contre les campagnes de SMS
frauduleux nous avons tous reçu des faux
SMS de la sécurité sociale des impôts de
la vignette critère nous avons tous
hésité à cliquer et en réalité ce sont
18 millions de Français qui ont été
victimes l'année dernière de la
cyberciminalité et en particulier les
Français les plus âgés les plus
vulnérables qui se retrouvent entraînés
dans la spirale infernale de
l'usurpation d'identité dont il mettent
parfois une décennie avant de se sortir
avec cette mesure nous voulons couper le
mal à la racine et je me réjouis des
travaux de la commission spéciale qui
ont permis de clarifier le rôle
notamment des navigateurs je pense au
rapporte aux amendement rapporteur et et
ce d'éc botorel dans le le le dispositif
et qui va permettre de le sécuriser de
le rendre un peu plus efficace on a
aussi préciser la définition du
hamsonnage dans le cadre de ces débats
deuxième mesure la peine de bannissement
peine complémentaire que le juge pourra
prononcer pour des faits de violence et
de harcèlement en ligne le harcèlement
se propage sur les réseaux sociaux les
respons les responsables en sont une
minorité d'internautes qui parfois se
comportent comme des chefs de meutes qui
désignent à leur communauté des victimes
et qui déclenchent sur eux des haines ou
sur ell des aides des raides de haine et
de violence et je dis sur elle puisque
les femmes sont 26 fois plus souvent
victimes de cyberhcèlement que les
hommes euh sur internet avec cette peine
de bannissement nous préviendrons la la
récidive en tapant ses chefs de meut là
où ça fait mal puisqu'en confisquant
leur notoriété nous les privons euh nous
les priverons de leur caisse de
résonance là aussi une mesure qui a été
renforcée sécurisée par la commission
spéciale et dont nous allons parler à
nouveau dans le cadre de l'examen en
séance troème mesure de protection
l'encadrement des jeux fondés sur les
chaînes de bloc fondés sur le web 3 ces
jeux existent depuis un certain nombre
d'années ils ne sont aujourd'hui l'objet
d'aucun cadre de protection protection
des mineurs protection contre les
addictions lutte contre le blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme le cadre
qui est proposé et là aussi je veux
saluer le le travail remarquable des
rapporteurs sur sur ce sujet permettra
de de faciliter le développement en
France
d'innovation
tout en protégeant celles et ceux qui
ont besoin de l'être au chapitre de la
protection de nos enfants ensuite une
mesure forte qui consiste à confier à
l'arcom le pouvoir d'ordonner le blocage
et le déréférencement des sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifieront pas
l'âge de leurs utilisateurs et il est
urgent de prendre cette mesure parce que
comme vous le savez ce sont plus de 2
millions d'enfants qui dans notre pays
sont exposés chaque mois au contenu
pornographique et à des âges extrêmement
précoces puisque'à 12 ans dans notre
pays P la moitié des petits garçons sont
exposés à ces contenus avec des
conséquences délétaires sur leur santé
et sur leur développement affectif
pourquoi parce que les sites
pornographiques ne vérifient pas l'âge
de leurs utilisateurs alors qu'ils y
sont tenus par la loi une procédure est
en cours qui ira jusqu'à son terme et
dont je souhaite que le le verdict soit
exemplaire mais pour l'avenir il nous
faut pouvoir agir plus vite et avec
cette mesure nous nous le pourrons
certaines inquiétudes se sont exprimées
pendant la Commission sur la confusion
possible entre les obligations de moyens
et les obligations de résultats qui
s'imposeront au sites pornographique les
rapporteurs ont proposé une rédaction
qui me semble aller dans le bon sens en
rappelant bien que l'obligation absolue
c'est celle de se conformer au code
pénal qui interdit à quiconque d'exposer
des mineurs dans notre pays à des
contenus pornographiques 2è mesure au
chapitre de la protection de nos enfants
euh la la peine d'un an de prison et
250000 € d'amende pour les hébergeurs
qui ne retireront pas en moins de 24
heures les contenus pédopornographiqu
qui leur sont signalés par les forces de
l'ordre l'année dernière ce sont
74000 contenus pédopornographiques qui
ont été signalés par Faros à des
hébergeurs aujourd'hui cette obligation
existe celle du retrait en moins de 24
heures mais elle n'est pas sanctionnée
par une amende ou par une peine de
prison à l'inverse de la peine déjà
prévue pour le non retrait de contenu
terroriste nous alignons avec cet
article les sanctions pour les le non
retrait des contenu pédopornographique
avec celui avec celle prévue pour le
nonretrait des contenus terroristes j'en
viens maintenant au chapitre de la
protection de nos entreprises et de nos
collectivités avec d'abord l'encadrement
des avoirs commerciaux
l'interopérabilité et l'interdiction des
frais de transfert dans le marché de
l'informatique en nuage c'est un marché
qui est extrêmement concentré entre les
mains de trois acteurs qui se sont
livrés à des pratiques déloyales pour
consolider au fil des années un
oligopole sur ce marché plaçant les
entreprises utilisatrices les
collectivités utilisatrices les
administrations utilisatrices dans une
situation d'assujétissement et de
dépendance nous devons mettre fin à la
loi du plus fort c'est une question de
souveraineté à laquelle avec Bruno Lemer
nous veillons extrêmement attentivement
avec ces mesures qui elles aussi ont
fait l'objet d'enrichissement et
d'apport nouveau par le travail des
rapporteurs et de la commission spéciale
nous rendrons euh de l'air et de la
liberté aux entreprises de France et au
au passage nous réouvrirons ce marché de
l'info de l'informatique en nuage qui
est aujourd'hui très significativement
verrouillé et puis une mesure de
protection pour nos collectivités avec
la création d'une plateforme unique pour
le respect de la réglementation en
matière de meublé de tourisme il s'agit
là de péréniser c'est une c'est un
souhait de la ministre Olivia Grégoire
une expérimentation qui a commencé il y
a quelques années associant cinq
collectivités avec 5 plateformes et qui
permettra de manière beaucoup plus
simple aux collectivités de faire
respecter en particulier la règle des
120 nuités j'en viens au 4e chapitre
celui de la protection de notre
démocratie avec le pouvoir donné à
l'arcom de mettre en
demeure et d'ordonner le blocage le cas
échéant des sites Internet qui
diffuseront des médias frappés par des
sanctions internationales à l'image de
celle que l'Union européenne a prise à
l'encontre de RT France et de Spoutnik
la désinformation est un véritable
poison pour nos démocrati avec cette
mesure qui elle aussi a été complété
utilement par des amendements de de
Quentin bataillon lors de l'examen de la
en commission et bien nous allons
compléter notre arsenal de mesures pour
lutter plus efficacement contre les
ennemis de la démocratie je veux saluer
à ce stade de mon propos le travail
remarquable du rapporteur général des
rapporteurs sur chacun des parties du
texte dont ils avaient la responsabilité
et des membres de la commission spéciale
qui ont contribué à l'enrichissement et
à la sécurité juridique du texte lors de
l'examen en commission et je vais salué
en particulier deux ajouts qui me
semblent absolument déterminants avec
l'adoption du stage de citoyenneté
numérique c'est les la la rapporteur et
Caroline yadan qui l'avait porté
qui pourra être prononcé comme une peine
complémentaire par un juge lorsqu'il
considère que cela est est nécessaire et
puis la fixation d'un objectif ambitieux
pour le déploiement de l'identité
numérique en France sujet porté par le
rapporteur général et je ne doute pas
que nos débats dans cette auguste
hémicycle nous permettront d'enrichir et
de sécuriser le le texte un peu plus
encore je souhaite en particulier que ce
débat nous permette de donner suite au
groupes de travail transpartisan sur les
violences urbaines de de la fin du mois
de juin auquel 15 groupes poli politiqu
ont
été ont souhaité s'associer avec
l'extension de la peine de bannissement
au provocation à la violence non suivie
des faits et la création d'une réserve
citoyenne du numérique et puis je
souhaite également que ce débat en
hémicycle nous permette aussi de
concrétiser le volet numérique du plan
de lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
que nous avons présenté la semaine
dernière avec la première ministre et le
ministre de l'éducation nationale avec
l'extension de la peine de bannissement
au contrôle judiciaire comme j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire en commission
mesdames et Messieurs les Députés il
nous faudra veiller collectivement à ne
jamais enfreindre les bornes que nous
fixent les engagements européens de la
France et notre Constitution les
engagements le respect des engagements
européens de la France c'est ce qui
permet à la France d'obtenir de grandes
victoires comme ça a été le cas à de
nombreuses reprises ces dernières années
et singulièrement en 2022 avec
l'adoption de DSA et de DMA on ne peut
pas tricoter de grandes victoires à
Bruxelles si on les détricote le lemain
en rentrant à Paris c'est parfois un peu
frustrant mais c'est une exigence que
l'on doit avoir quand on Orte pour
l'Europe une une vision ambitieuse et
quant à notre Constitution elle veille à
ce que les mesures que nous prenons les
mesures indispensables que nous prenons
pour sécuriser l'espace numérique ne
viennent pas enfreintre de manière
disproportionnée les libertés
fondamentales et je pense évidemment à
la liberté d'information et la liberté
d'expression mesdames et messieurs les
députés la France ne tiendra pas son
rang de grandes nation numérique si les
français et notamment les plus
vulnérables ne se sentent pas en
sécurité sur Internet ce constat je sais
que nous le partageons très largement et
quant aux réponses à lui apporter je
sais pouvoir compter sur la sagesse de
l'Assemblée alors merci
beaucoup merci Monsieur le
Ministre la parole est à Monsieur Paul
midi rapporteur général de la commission
spéciale
merci madame la
Présidente cher Monsieur le Ministre
cher jean- Noël chers rapporteur chers
collègues alors c'est une très bonne
nouvelle que l'Assemblée nationale
travaille sur ce projet de loi de
sécurisation et de régulation de
l'espace numérique c'est un sujet qui
est au cœur de notre quotidien et je
suis convaincu que nous pouvons
rassembler sur ce texte l'ensemble de
nos compatriotes au-delà des clivages
politiques traditionnel nous avons tous
collectivement beaucoup travaillé sur le
sujet avec des débats de très grande
qualité en commission comme je l'espère
nous les aurons dans cet hémicycle
aujourd'hui nous passons déjà plus de
temps dans l'espace numérique que dans
l'espace public en moyenne ce sont 4
heures par jour que les Français passent
dans l'espace numérique et même pour nos
jeunes de 15 à 24 ans 4 heures par jour
et ça continue d'augmenter chaque année
alors cet espace numérique ce sont bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux ce sont les
plateformes de contenu vidéo ce sont nos
magasins en ligne sont nos jeux vidéos
ou encore ce sont nos musées en euh
version virtuelle cet espace numérique
c'est un espace d'opportunité immense
c'est un espace de lien entre les uns et
les autres de partage avec les amis la
famille avec l'ensemble des concitoyens
de la communauté nationale européenne et
mondiale c'est un espace de création
fantastique l'espace numérique c'est un
espace de libertés individuelle qui sont
très importantes notamment la liberté
que s'exprimer bien sûr mais aussi la
liberté de s'informer mais cet espace
numérique c'est un petit peu aujourd'hui
le Far West plus de 50 % de nos jeunes
disent s'être fait harceler en ligne
avec des conséquences bien souvent trop
dramatique je pense par exemple au cas
très récent de Manon Lanza qui après son
accident dans GP explorer s'est fait
littéralement lyché harcelé de remarques
CCIS par des milliers d'internautes mais
je pense aussi au suicide de la jeune
Linsey cyber harcelé à l'école et à
l'appel de sa mère à la puissance
publique pour combattre je je la cite
l'impunité sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ne peuvent continuer à gagner de
l'argent sur les propos aineux et
injurieux je ne veux pas moi vivre dans
un monde où parce que tout le monde se
sent anonyme il y a un sentiment
d'impunité et ça donne un suicide suite
à du harcellement toutes les 2 semaines
et un niveau de violence inégalé dans le
monde
physique 2è point 50 % des arnaques ont
maintenant lieu en ligne sont 9 millions
de Français de nos compatriotes qui
perdent de l'argent dans ces arnaques
nous avons tous reçu
ce type de SMS par exemple pour les
fausses amondes et ce sont aussi 80 % de
nos enfants parfois les plus jeunes qui
ont été exposé à la pornographie à cause
d'Internet avec des troubles maintenant
prouvés sur leur comportement à
l'adolescence et à l'âge adulte et puis
d'une façon générale pour ceux comme 80
% des Français qui sont utilisateurs
quotidiens des réseaux sociaux c'est
misogynie sexisme racisme antisémitisme
islamophobie et LGBT phobie à tous les
étages et nous devons donc trouver les
moyens d'y mettre fin le chtier donc
immense pour rendre notre espace
numérique aussi civilisé et sûr que
notre espace physique il s'agit non pas
d'inventer de nouvelles règles et de
changer l'équilibre de nos lois de notre
cadre de liberté mais il s'agit de
transposer les règles du monde physique
dans l'espace numérique il ne s'agit pas
de réinventer le fil à couper le beurre
mais de faire simplement que ce qui est
illégal dans le monde physique
conformément aux lois que nous avons mis
quelques siècles à écrire et à voter
dans ce pays que ce qui soit illégal
dans le monde physique soit illégal dans
le monde numérique concrètement grâce à
ce texte grâce au travail du
gouvernement grâce au travail de
l'ensemble des députés et tous ceux qui
ont participé à la commission nous
combattrons le cyberhcèlement à tous les
niveaux d'abord grâce à la mise en place
de mesures d'éducation et de formation
de nos jeunes de leurs parents et de
leurs professeurs en responsabilisant
beaucoup plus fortement les plateformes
de réseaux sociaux grâce au DSA et en
punissant les cyberhceleurs avec la mise
en place d'amende et la peine de
bannissement des réseaux sociaux nous
combattrons les arnaques en ligne grâce
au filtrre anti-arnaque qui doit
protéger nos concitoyens contre les
arnaques quasi quotidiennes dont nous
faisons tous l'objet grâce à ce texte
nous pourrons protéger les mineurs de
l'exposition à la pornographie avec des
solutions et des mesures concrètes ce
texte sera aussi l'occasion de mieux
réguler un certain nombre d'activités
dans le monde numérique comme
l'informatique en nuage pour renforcer
la concurrence les jeux à objet
numérique monétisable pour soutenir
l'innovation et protéger nos jeunes ou
encore la location des meublés de
tourisme pour soutenir nos collectivités
territorial enfin nous permettrons bien
sûr les changements législatifs pour
appliquer les règlements du DSA et du
DMA mis en place par l'Union européenne
à l'occasion de la présidence française
vous voyez chers collègues le chantier
est immense nous sommes au début de
l'histoire de cet espace numérique et je
nous souhaite donc à tous un très bon
travail collectif et je suis avec les
rapport orteur avant entière disposition
merci à tous merci monsieur le
rapporteur
général la parole est à Madame Louise
Morel pardon rapporteur de la commission
[Applaudissements]
spéciale madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale mesdames et messieur
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues nous entamons aujourd'hui
l'examen du projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
et je voudrais commencer mon propos en
remerciant l'intégralité des députés qui
ont pris part aux travaux préparatoires
à l'examen de ce texte pour la qualité
de nos échanges ces travaux
préparatoires ce sont plus de 50
auditions une centaine d'experts du
numérique rencontrés et 30h de débat au
stade de la commission spéciale je
voudrais saluer sur tous les bancs de
notre assemblée
la volonté sincère de chacun des députés
qui ont pris part à ces travaux de mieux
réguler l'espace numérique de sécuriser
la navigation en ligne et d'améliorer la
qualité de l'expérience de nos
concitoyens sur
internet internet il faut le rappeler
c'est d'abord un formidable espace de
liberté où chacun peut s'exprimer en
lieu où naissent des projets de toutes
sortes où les réseaux sociaux peuvent
nous rassembler quel que soit l'endroit
de la planète sur lequel nous vivons
mais interet c'est aussi des images
pédocriminelles en libre accès des cyber
violences multiples des escroqueries
massives nous avons aujourd'hui
l'opportunité de mettre fin au sentiment
d'impunité en ligne et pour cela il nous
faut interdire en ligne ce qui est
interdit hors ligne nous ne pouvons pas
tolérer en 2023 que des enfants victimes
de cyberhcellement vont jusqu'à se
suicider face à cette souffrance nous ne
pouvons pas tolérer que 18 18 millions
de nos concitoyens soient victimes
chaque année d'arnaque en ligne nous ne
pouvons pas non plus tolérer que des
mineurs par un simple clic en quelques
secondes accède à des millions d'images
pornographiques alors que ce type de
contenu est interdit dans la vie réelle
pour toutes ces raisons il a fallu bâtir
un texte qui pose des interdits qui
sanctionne des comportements illicites
en ligne j'ai eu l'honneur d'être nommé
rapporteur thématique des titres 1 et 2
de ce projet de loi et je voudrais
revenir sur les avancées très concrètes
qu'il apporte dans la vie quotidienne de
nos concitoyens sur le Titre 1 d'abord
qui entend protéger les mineurs en ligne
nous mettons en place dans ce texte
l'obligation pour les sites
pornographiques d'installer un mécanisme
de vérification robuste de l'âge de
leurs utilisateurs sous peine de Lourdes
sanction pour compléter les échanges que
nous avons eu en commission et pour
assurer que cette nouvelle obligation de
moyens se cumule avec l'obligation de
résultats qui émane de l'article 227 24
du code pénal je vous proposerai
quelques amendements qui renforceront
encore ce double objectif je précise
également que les procès en cours devant
le juge judiciaire iront bien à leur
terme toujours sur le sujet de la
pornographie ce texte donne à l'autorité
administrative la possibilité d'obliger
les hébergeurs à retirer en moins de 24
heures les contenus pédopornographiques
en ligne le non respect de cette
disposition c'est un an d'emprisonnement
et 250000 € d'amende nous portons ainsi
un coup d'arrêt au développement des
réseaux
pédocriminels sur le titre 2 ensuite ce
projet de loi entend protéger plus
largement les citoyens dans
l'environnement numérique cela passe par
la lutte contre le cyber harcèlement
aujourd'hui ayons bien à l'esprit que
près de 60 % des 1825 ans ont déjà été
victimes de
cyberhcèlement nous apportons dans ce
texte une réponse pénale en permettant
au juges d'infliger une peine complément
ire de bannissement des réseaux sociaux
pour les auteurs de ce type de violence
enfin ce texte entend lutter contre les
arnaques toujours plus nombreuses et
plus élaborées sur Internet beaucoup de
nos concitoyens se reconnaîtront dans
quelques sms que j'ai reçu votre colis a
été livré veuillez le récupérer en
cliquant sur ce lien urgent vous allez
perdre vos droits au compte personnel de
formation ou encore critère nos agents
ont constaté que vous n'étiez pas munis
de la vinette réglementaire veuillez la
réc opéré sur ce lien je pourrais
multiplier les exemples ils agacent
légitimement nos concitoyens et ses
visent partout ce projet de loi
permettra une fois une arnaque signalée
d'être redirigée vers une page qui
avertira l'utilisateur du caractère
frauduleux du site sur lequel il se
dirige mesdames et messieurs les députés
je manque de temps pour vous partager
l'intégralité des avancées de ce texte
mais je voudrais vous dire la fierté qui
est la mienne d'être rapporteur sur un
texte qui entend sincèrement améliorer
le rapport au numérique de nos
concitoyens pour conclure je dirais que
nous avons la chance en France et en
Europe d'avoir des acteurs qui cultivent
une culture de l'innovation numérique et
qui porte les valeurs de progrès qui
sont chères à notre pays ils ont des
solutions pour empêcher ces violences en
ligne et il nous appartiendra dans ce
texte de leur donner en cadre en
veillant avec beaucoup d'humilité à
trouver le juste équilibre entre
sanctions nécessaires et préservation
des libertés fondamentales sur internet
je vous
remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame Anne
Le le le j'arriverai jamais leenonf
pardon rapporteur de la commission
spéciale toutes mes
excuses merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur général chers
collègues je me réjouis de vous
retrouver aujourd'hui pour l'examen en
séance du projet de loi sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique j'ai j'ai eu
l'honneur en tant que rapporteur du
titre 3 de suivre l'encadrement du
marché de l'informatique en nuage
notamment des crédit Cloud et des frais
de transfert mais également la
sécurisation de l'hébergement des
données la portabilité ou encore
l'interopérabilité je tiens à saluer ici
le travail de nos collègues sénateurs
qui ont enrichi ce texte et soulevé des
débats que nous ne manquerons pas de
poursuivre dans cet hémicycle et de tous
nos collègues pour le travail effectué
depuis plusieurs semaines merci
également aux acteurs du domaine qui
jusqu'à la dernière minute ont contribué
à m'éclairer et proposer un titre 3 le
plus réaliste possible le titre 3
anticipe en grande partie le règlement
européen du Data Act afin de favoriser
la concurrence sur le marché du cloud en
régulant certaines pratiques tout en
soutenant nos acteurs français et
européens ce projet de loi s'inscrit
dans la continuité des fortes évolutions
intervenues dans le domaine du droit
européen DSA DMA data Act ces règlements
ont permis d'harmoniser notre droit et
de faire de réelles avancé dans le
domaine du numérique je m'en félicite
d'autant plus que les positions
françaises ont été largement suivies par
nos partenaires sur un ensemble de
sujets clés cette trajectoire n'est pas
achevée il nous reste à adopter au
niveau européen la version définitive du
Data Act par ailleurs les négociations
sur l'iucs schéma européen de
certification de sécurité sont toujours
en cours et la France y prend
actuellement toute sa part il nous faut
donc garder à l'esprit et c'est ce que
je me suis efforcé à faire tout au long
des auditions que nous avons mené et
pendant nos débats qu'au-delà de
l'adaptation de notre droit au textes
européens déjà finalisé nous devons
également pour ce qui est de la partie
où nous anticipons les textes européens
trouver le juste équilibre pour adopter
des dispositions qui soient conformes
autant que possible aux négociations en
cours au Sénat comme en commission
spéciale la protection des données et
plus particulièrement leur hébergement
ou encore la transparence sur leurs
conditions de sauvegarde ont été au cœur
des débat c'est un sujet essentiel et
j'ai la conviction qu'il nous faut
trouver des solutions efficaces et
pragmatiques en nous appuyant sur
l'expertise des acteurs auditionnés mais
aussi sur la réalité du contexte que ce
soit sur le plan opérationnel ou
réglementaire français comme européen
c'est dans ce cadre que j'ai déposé en
commission un amendement de suppression
de l'article 10 B a on dit souvent que
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions
l'article 10 B a en est un parfait
exemple en inscrivant un tel dispositif
dans la loi nous ne ferions qu'affaiblir
à la fois la position française au
niveau européen mais surtout la filière
cloud française au-delà même de l'aspect
non opérationnel du dispositif proposé
je tiens à à rappeler qu'il existe déjà
un certain nombre de dispositifs
législatifs et réglementaires qui ont
été mis en place ces dernières années
très souvent d'ailleurs à l'initiative
de la France l'a rappelé le ministre
tout à l'heure le rgpd le référentiel
secnum cloud le référentiel HDS pour les
données de santé lequel connaît
actuellement une révision de même la
circulaire du 31 mai dernier actualisant
la doctrine dite cloud auocentre établit
un cadre réglementaire pour les données
des administrations centrales sur ce
dernier point j'ai la conviction qu'il
va nous falloir aller d'ailleurs plus
vite et plus loin enfin la filière du
cloud français est en train de se
structuré nous avons des entreprises de
grande qualité et nombre d'entre elles
sont engagées dans une offre de cloud
sécurisé sécurisé secnum cloud ou en
cours de certification elles ont une
ambition celle d'occuper une place de
premier plan sur le marché du cloud
européen cette ambition nécessite du
temps un env environnement porteur un un
accompagnement de la part de l'État et
une organisation de la filière instaurer
dès maintenant une norme
franco-française serait contre-productif
les législateurs que nous sommes devons
trouver un équilibre entre deux
priorités protéger les données de nos
concitoyens et organisations tout en
créant l'environnement propice au
développement d'une filière cloud
française sur un marché de 450 millions
d'habitants je me réjouis d'avance des
débats qui s'ouvrent aujourd'hui dans
cet hémicycle sur un texte d'importance
majeure pour la France je vous
remercie merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame mirïe
claapau rapporteur de la commission
[Applaudissements]
spéciale merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs rapporteur chers collègues
nous examinons aujourd'hui un texte qui
porte de nombreuses avancées pour nos
concitoyens je me réjouis de voir que
nous prenons à bras-lecp la protection
des mineurs en ligne les arnaques la
question de la désinformation qui mine
notre société je tiens par ailleurs à
saluer le travail de la commission
supérieure du numérique et des postes où
députés et sénateurs œuvrent ensemble
pour produire des recommandations sur
l'espace numérique j'aimerais mentionner
ici deux avis de la csnp rendu récemment
le premier sur la protection des mineurs
à l'initiative de la sénatrice Toan
bourra l'autre sur la souveraineté
numérique dont le groupe de travail a
été mené par Anne leenanf rapporteur des
articles sur la cloud que nous venons
d'entendre pour ma part comme rapporteur
sur les titres 5 et 6 je analysais plus
précisément les articles 16 17 et 18
dont j'aimerais vous dire un mot ils
sont techniques mais ils sont essentiels
pour avancer vers une meilleure
compréhension des plateformes en ligne
et des données qu'ell collectent
l'article 17 d'abord seul article
concernant les collectivités avec la
création d'une interface numérique sur
un sujet très sensible pour les communes
les données relatives à la location des
meublés de tourisme vous connaissez
l'engouement croissant des touristes
pour les locations chez l'habitant et le
succès des plateformes qui mett en
relation touristes et loueurs la
législation en particulier la loi élan a
donné de nouvelles possibilités de
contrôle aux communes et des obligations
aux plateformes et aux
propriétaires les communes qui ont
choisi de mettre en place la
réglementation du changement d'usage et
un numéro d'enregistrement peuvent
aujourd'hui solliciter les
intermédiaires de location pour obtenir
des données sur les meublés loués sur
leur
territoire cependant la transmission
aujourd'hui ne se fait qu'une fois par
an manuellement via des fichers Excel ce
qui est difficilement exploitable par
les communes l'article 17 prévoit donc
qu'un organisme unique sera chargé de
collecter les données auprès des
plateformes et de les communiquer
ensuite aux communes qui en font la
demande il est estimé qu'environ 350
communes pourraient bénéficier de ce
dispositif c'est une réelle avancée qui
va permettre notamment aux communes de
mieux contrôler le respect par les
loueurs de cette fameuse limite de 120
jours de location pour les résidences
principales et un de mes amendements
adoptés en commission permettra même une
alerte dès que ce délai est dépassé cet
outils qui a été expérimenté dans cinq
communes a rencontré tellement de succès
qu'on nous a proposé de l'élargir à
toutes des communes et a davantage de
données pour en faire un outil de
pilotage de la politique de logement de
tourisme des communes mais comme par
ailleurs un règlement européen est en
cours de négociation sur le sujet je
pense prudent de rester dans le cadre de
cette loi Seren sur un cadre maîtrisé
pour réussir l'extension de cet outils
aux 350 communes
concernées au cours de ces travaux la
commission spéciale a adopté plusieurs
amendements d'abord elle a élargi le
spectre des données pouvant être
transmis par les plateformes à
l'ensemble des données utiles pour mener
une politique publique du tourisme et de
logement ces données seront accessible
en source ouvertes pour être exploité
par tous et pas seulement par les
communes un comité de suivi de la mise
en œuvre de cette interface sera
également mise en place et comprendra
notamment des représentants des communes
enfin pour dissiper tout malentendu la
commission spéciale a précisé que cet
organisme chargé de collecter les
données seraient publ
pour ce qui concerne les articles 16 et
18 il porte précisément sur Le Pen le
pôle d'expertise de la régulation
numérique dont je salue l'ex excellence
l'article 16 précise que Le Pen peut
mener des recherches sur les risques
systémiques au titre du DSA et élargit
son accès aux données publiquement
accessibles des plateformes en ligne ces
activités d'expérimentation et de
recherche sont très précieuses et c'est
pourquoi nous avons en commission élargi
encore le champ de compét au système
d'intelligence artificielle
générative quant à l'article 18 il il
fixe les modalités de la collaboration
entre Le Pen et LARCOM ce dernier étant
désigné par le présentex comme
coordinateur pour les services
numériques en France ces deux servic
collabor déjà mais il était nécessaire
de l'inscrire dans la loi l'arcom pourra
ainsi plus facilement s'appuyer sur
l'expertise technique du PEN pour mener
à bien ses nouvelles
missions je conclus en saluant l'esprit
constructif qui a prévalu dans les des
travaux en commission je ne doute pas
qu'il en sera de même dans nos futures
discussions en gardant à l'esprit le
respect des libertés fondamentales et
des normes européennes comme la langue
des opes le numérique c'est la meilleure
et la pire des choses faisons en sorte
de n'en garder que le meilleur je vous
remercie pour votre
attention merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Monsieur
Denis Masseglia rapporteur de la
commission
spéciale
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
députons aujourd'hui les débats en
séance sur le projet de loi visant à
sécuriser l'espace numérique pour lequel
j'ai l'honneur d'être rapporteur pour
les titres 4 et
7 j'ouvrirai mon propos sur le titre 7
dont les dispositions vont permettre une
mise en conformité avec le rgpd en
établissant des autorités de contrôle
dédié au traitement de données au sein
des différents ordres
juridictionnels vient ensuite le vient
ensuite le titre 4 celui portant sur les
jeux à objet numérique monétisable les
jaunum ces jeux existent en France
depuis plusieurs années évoluant
jusque-l sans faire l'objet d'aucune
réglementation l'enjeu ici encadrer
l'activité de ces d'entreprise dans une
logique de soutien à l'innovation et de
protection des
consommateurs en raison de la nouveauté
de ces acteurs c'est une expérimentation
de 3 ans avec un point d'étape à 18 mois
que nous proposons tout d'abord de
mettre en œuvre pour à terme fixer un
régime adapté aux réalités de ce secteur
émergent en commission nous sommes venus
renforcer la définition proposée par le
Sénat nous nous som nous avons surtout
créé un cadre strict pour cette
expérimentation certaines préoccupations
ont été soulevées lors de cet examen
aussi dans la perspective de la séance
et j'avais pris l'engagement de
travailler avec chaque collègue qui le
souhaitait en travaillant bien sûr avec
la majorité mais aussi les oppositions
pour aboutir ensemble à des propositions
constructives visant à renforcer la
protection des publics sensibles et
c'est ce que nous avons fait le cadre
que nous avons voté en commission vient
imposer au jeunum un certain nombre
d'obligations sous la supervision de
l'autorité nationale des jeux celle-ci
aura en effet le pouvoir de contrôler le
respect de leurs obligations par les
entreprises de les mettre en demeure et
même de les sanctionner à noter que la
mission ainsi confié à l'anj est lourde
et elle impliquera en effet que nous lui
donnons des ressources supplémentaires
dans le cadre du PLF il faudra que nous
soyons vigilants pour augmenter les
moyens que nous allons lui allouer
ce cadre s'apprête à être enrichi par un
certain nombre d'amendements pour lequel
je serais favorable et qui résulte pour
certains de ce travail de construction
transpartisan je souhaite revenir sur
trois d'entre eux premier point
d'atention les casino en ligne certains
souhaitent profiter de ce véhicule
législatif pour les légaliser d'autres
au contraire s'en inquièteent vivement
je le redis fermement il n'est pas
question ici d'autoriser cette forme de
jeu de hasard et de d'argent et de
hasard illégal les casinos en ligne sont
interdits ils doivent le rester le
second point attention les obligations
en matière de lutte contre l'addiction
il n'existe pas à ce jour de données
formalisé sur ce sujet en raison de la
jeunesse de ces entreprises mais il
apparaît indispensable de pouvoir
caractériser à terme les éventuels
risques qui leur seraient associés c'est
pourquoi nous proposons ici que le
rapport rendu à
mi-expérimentation devra faire l'état de
l'impact sanitaire de celle-ci sur les
joueurs en terme
d'addiction troisième point d'attention
certainement un des plus importants
l'accès des mineurs au jeunumes son
interdiction est déjà inscrite dans
l'article 15 bis tel que voté en
commission mais nous avons souhaité
répondre favorablement aux
préoccupations de certains de nos
collègues vis-à-vis de la possibilité
laisser aux entreprises de se contentter
d'un système déclaratif c'est pourquoi
avec les amendements déposés par les
groupes Renaissance modem et horizon
nous exigeons désormais que les
entreprises utilisent un dispositif
permettant de façon effective de
vérifier la majorité enfin je seraiis
défavorable à tout amendement qui
viendrait affaiblir ce cadre et donc la
protection des publics les plus
sensible supprimer les articles 15 et 15
bis comme le proposent certains et je
pense à la France insoumise pour ne pas
les citer et à minima contreproductif si
ce n'est
irresponsable car la conséquence serait
très simple il laisserait évoluer
librement sans régulation ses
entreprises résultat aucune protection
contre l'addiction aucune protection
contre le blanchimement d'argent et
peut-être que vous souhaitez que les
enfants de 6 ans soient sur les jaunumes
c'est votre choix c'est pas le ntre avec
les articles 15 et 15 bis que nous avons
voté et que nous apprêtons à a amender
nous nous inscrivons parfaitement dans
le double objectif qui est le nottre
soutenir l'innovation sur nos
territoires tout en assurant la
protection des consommateurs en
particulier des publics sensibles avec
les articles 15 et 15 bis de ce projet
de loi la France sera le premier pays au
monde à se doter d'une régulation pour
cet écosystème je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur Luc
lamirot président de la commission
spéciale
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs thématiques madame la
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
européennes mes chers collègues Mac
Andresen l'un des développeurs de
mosaïque le premier navigateur web
complet nous avait averti il y a presque
10 ans le logiciel dévore le monde il
prédisait ainsi un bouleversement majeur
de l'ensemble du monde économique du
fait de la révolution numérique mais au
au-delà du strict champ économique il
nous appartient en tant que législateur
de nous assurer que le numérique ne
dévore pas dans le même mouvement les
citoyens en particulier les plus
fragiles
et au premier chef d'entre eux les
mineurs tel est l'objet du présent
projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique ù serine pour
les intimes tâche essentielle mais au
combien ardu une exigence d'humilité
s'impose par nature au législateur
elle est d'autant plus forte dès lors
que son action porte sur le champ
numérique en un espace en perpétuel
mouvement en recomposition permanente
avec des ruptures soudaines et des
innovations qui émergent à une vitesse
vertigineuse sans doute davantage que
dans les autres champs de la vie sociale
et économique l'ouvrage devra donc être
remis sur le métier il faut en être
conscient et l'accepter avec
modestie néanmoins cette exigence
d'humilité ne doit pas aboutir à une
forme de paralysie collective et de
renon de la part des pouvoirs publics
elle doit être conciliée avec une autre
exigence d'égale importance qui est
celle de l'action lucide mais
déterminé le numérique a créé un monde
propre des mondes en réalité mais il
n'est pas hors du monde
physique car derrière toute action
entreprise toute parole prononcée dans
l'espace numérique il y a des
conséquences dans le monde réel sur la
vie bien réelle sur des personnes faites
de chair et de sang et non d'une
succession de 0 et de 1 comme un code
binaire ces conséquences peuvent être
anodines et parfaitement légales l'achat
d'un bien d'un service le partage de
connaissan ou encore l'accès aux arts et
à la culture
elles peuvent aussi être délétair et
constituer des actes
délictuels voire criminels jusqu'à
briser des vies c'est pourquoi l'action
du législateur est parfaitement légitime
en dépit des spécificités objectives
d'un espace sans frontières qui efface
les distances et écrase le temps et qui
de fait remet en question les
déterminants classiques d'une action
publique qui s'inscrit par nature dans
un espace
fini des initiatives ont déjà prospéré à
l'image de l'importante proposition de
loi défendue par le président de notre
groupe Laurent marcangelli visant à
instaurer une majorité numérique et à
lutter contre la haine en
ligne définitivement adoptée par le
Parlement elle a été promulguée en
juillet dernier la commission spéciale
constituée pour examiner ce projet de
loi que j'ai eu l'honneur de présider a
fait je crois œuvre utile nous avons
examiné plus de 660 amendements au cours
de 25 he de débat à la suite de nos
collègues sénateurs qui avaient déjà
enrichi le texte nous l'avons amélioré
complété sécurisé si nous défendons des
options parfois
différentes je suis persuadé que nous
partageons sur l'ensemble des bans le
même objectif celui d'assurer à nos
concitoyens la meilleure protection
possible dans l'espace numérique dans le
respect des libertés et droits
fondamentaux et de nos engagements
internation internationaux notamement
européens cet objectif partagé c'est s
traduit au cours de nos travaux en
commission avec l'adoption d'amendements
de la majorité comme des oppositions je
ne reviendrai pas dans le détail sur les
modifications apportées aux différents
articles que les rapporteurs ont avant
moi
présenté je ne doute pas que le texte
recueillera un accord large au sein de
notre assemblée déjà
déjà considérablement enrichi amélioré
lors des débats en commission spéciale
il le sera sans doute encore à l'issu de
notre examen en séance publique pour
finir je souhaite remercier sincèrement
l'ensemble des collègues de tous les
groupes politiques qui ont participé aux
travaux de la commission spéciale nos
débats ont été denses riches mais
toujours sereins je forme le vœ qu'il le
soit de même dans les jours à venir je
vous
remercie merci Monsieur le présid
président la parole est à Madame
Marietta caramonli rapporteur pour
observation de la commission des
affaires
européennes madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues la
commission donc des affaires européennes
s'est saisie pour observation du projet
de loi visant à sécuriser réguler
l'espace numérique l'échelon bien sûr
européen est plus que jamais pertinent
pour lutter contre la touteepuissance
des grandes plateformes remettre de
l'ordre dans le phosest numérique je
salue la part prise par la France pour
parvenir à un compromis à la fois sur le
règlement sur les services numériques
desa visant à encadrer les activités des
plateformes en particulier cell des gfem
il est entré en vigueur pour les plus
grosse plateforme le 25 août dernier et
et le règlement également sur les
marchés numérique ou le DMA et visant
lui à lutter contre les pratiques
anticoncurrentielles des mêmes géants
d'Internet l'Union européenne joue un
rôle pionnier pour établir un
environnement en ligne qui soit
équitable sûr et responsable c'est un
motif de satisfaction une première étape
qui nous oblige notre rapport pour
observation formule une série de
recommandations pour améliorer je dirais
le DSA et le DMA en en moyen terme à
l'occasion de leur réexamen mais
également à court terme au titre de la
phase de mise en œuvre qui s'ouvre
j'appelle en particulier la France avec
d'autres partenaires européens à saisir
la commission pour ouvrir une enquête de
marché à l'encontre du réseau x
anciennement Twitter la première liste
de contrôleurs d'accès soumis au DMA
dévoiléit le moins dernier par la
commission comporte six acteurs qui
entignent les seuils quantitatifs fixés
par le le texte le réseau x n'y figure
pas et répond pourtant à plusieurs
critères qualitatifs qui peuvent être
mobilisé à titre subsidiaire attention
au risque d'incohérence Twitter serait
une très grande plateforme en ligne au
sens de DSA mais pas un contrôleur
d'accès au sens de DMA l'Allemagne en en
décembre 2022 a appelé justement
désigner le réseau x comme contrôleur
d'accès sans succès à ce stade en
commission spéciale gouvernement nous a
envoyé une aux enquêtes de marché
ouvertes par la commission mais le
réseau X n'est pas concerné d'après nos
informations donc la France a poussé
pour une législation européenne
ambitieuse soyons également ferme
monsieur le ministre et exigeant dans
son application et je sais que je peux
compter sur votre engagement je souhaite
poursuivre aussi mon propos en formulant
deux autres point de vigilance qui porte
spécifiquement sur les dispositions du
projet de loi en premier lieu c'est la
volonté du gouvernement de prétransposer
les textes européens en cours de
discussion afin de guillonner les
négociations me semble un peu
contestable il est important que la
France fasse valoir ses intérêts c'est
tout l'objet des échanges au Conseil de
l'Union en revanche la pratique de la
prétransposition crée un risque
d'incompatibilité native à vouloir
quelque fois tordre un peu le bras comme
je le disais en commission de ses
partenaires la France peut se retrouver
un petit peu le bras tordu j'en veux
pour preuve l'encadrement des crédits
cloud qui figure dans le projet de loi
mais qui a été écarté du compromis
trouvé avec l'Union sur le le la data
acte en juin une approche européenne
donc aurait permis de sécuriser le
dispositif qui déroge au principe de li
de libre prestation du pays d'origine et
la session en commission spéciale de
l'article 7 n'apporte pas de garantie à
la matière d'autre part je m'inquiète du
du risque de contrat variété avec le
droit de l'Union qui frappe certaines
dispositions du projet de loi le
gouvernement propose par exemple de
nommer la
DGCRF parmi les autorités nationales
compétentes chargé de la mise en œuvre
du DSA et ce alors même que le
considérant du 112 du DSA précise que
les entités désignées doivent agir en
toute indépendance et ne pas recevoir
d'instruction y compris du gouvernement
vous en conviendre V que la DGCCRF est
une est un service de Bery et qui agit
donc sur l'autorité de son ministre de
tutelle voilà quelqu chose qu'il faudra
peut-être effectivement faire évoluer à
l'avenir pour conclure il est
regrettable que on estit engagé la
procédure accéléré sur ce texte le délai
d'examen sont les déam sont extrêmement
courts notre Parlement devrait de toute
évidence adopter le projet de loi en
première lecture avant même que la
Commission européenne n'est pu présenter
ces observations dans le cadre de la
procédure de notification prévue par la
directive ecommerce à quoi donc cette
procédure de notification sert-elle si
nous ne prenons pas le temps à d'échange
d'échanger des informations avec les
autorités européennes et l'vidé donc de
sa substance de tant que nous nous
parlementaires ne sommes pas associés
aux échanges informels entre le
Gouvernement et la commission alors
voilà brièvement ce que je voulais dire
madame la Présidente les questions les
quelques réflexions que je souhaitais
partager avec vous mais je sais
qu'ontait aussi finalement dans le début
les formation échang formation qu'
pourra avoir ici pour faire évoluer le
le texte et aussi les discussions avec
la Commission européenne merci Madame la
rapporteur j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde
Panau et des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale une motion de
rejet préalable déposée en application
de l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à Madame sia Chikirou pour
une durée ne pouvant excéder 15
minutes présidente merci Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues le dépôt de
cette motion de rejet nous est apparu à
mon groupe et moi comme une nécessité le
texte de loi que vous nous proposez pour
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
est un faonet vous l'avez reconnu
vous-même lorsqu'on vous a auditionné en
commission spécial monsieur le ministre
barreau je cite exactement votre réponse
quand je vous faisais remarquer
l'insuffisance et l'inefficacité de
votre loi pour relever les défis
pourtant importants du numérique vous
m'avez répondu avec l'honnêteté qui vous
caractérise
je suis d'accord avec vous ce texte en
lui-même ne peut rien résoudre c'est un
aveu à la fois honnête en effet et
triste car justement il y a une urgence
à mettre un coup d'arrêt aux abus des
plateformes internet à la maltraitance
au harcèlement numérique et tout
particulièrement à l'exposition des plus
jeunes à un Internet aux mains
d'industriels sans scrupule avant
d'exposer toutes les raisons de cette
motion de rejet permettez-moi quand même
de verser à votre crédit en plus de
votre honnêteté lors du débat en
commission une autre qualité vous avez
fait l'effort de parler avec les
différents groupes parlementaires et
c'est assez rare pour être souligné
parce que nous la France à soumise nous
avons eu le droit à deux rendez-vous qui
nous ont permis de se dire nos profonds
désaccords je salue aussi du coup la
qualité qui est la même de monsieur le
rapporteur général Paul midi qui a
permis que le travail parlementaire se
fasse dans une une atmosphère
respectueuse des divergences ceci dit
j'en viens en raison de cette motion de
rejet nous estimons que nous ne pouvons
pas voter cette loi monsieur le ministre
vous mettez dans ce texte de loi pelmel
la lutte contre la péd pornographie la
lutte contre les ingérences étrangères
contre le cyberhcèlement contre
l'exposition des mineurs à la
pornographie le contrôle des nuités de
location saisonnière la désignation de
signaleurs de confiance la lutte contre
les révoltes urbaines et les
manifestations non déclaré les arnaques
en ligne et au milieu de tout ça un
article que nous appelons tous ici
l'article S R pour permettre à une
entreprise l'entreprise Sare de jeux
d'argent d'échapper aux règles et à la
fiscalité des jeux d'argent alors
évidemment ce Gloubi bouga est indigeste
aussi bien pour les enfants qui ne
seront pas protégés à plus protégés
avant qu'après cette loi et pour les
adultes qui risquent de voir leurs
libertés individuelles gravement mises
en péril quelle est donc la portée de
cette loi pour protéger les enfants si
j'en crois la tribune publiée par les
représentants de respect zone contre la
prostitution des enfants le Conseil
français des associations pour les
Droits de l'Enfant caméléon association
France stop VO enfant sans violence
l'Observatoire de la parentalité et de
l'éducation numérique les associations
crise internationale éveil la Fondation
pour l'enfance et même l'alliance des
avocats pour les droits de l'homme cette
loi est une régression même par rapport
à la législation existante je les cite
pour que vous ne prétendiez pas que
c'est une posture que j'emprunterai là
voilà ce que ces défenseurs des enfants
écrit IVe la majorité présidentielle
vote une loi c'était celle de 2020 dont
la constitutionnalité est confirmée et
qui est sur le point d'être appliquée et
puis cette même majorité sabote le
dispositif existant au dernier moment en
votant une nouvelle loi qui s'apparente
à une véritable bouée de sauvetage pour
les géants du porno et qui affaiblit la
protection des enfants et toutes ces
associations là vous demande de retirer
le Titre 1 monsieur barraau nous les
insoumis nous demandons aussi que la
réalité que ces experts décrivent soit
prise en compte et je demande ici aux
députés qui sont assis sur tous les
rangs d'avoir en tête cette déclaration
des associations au moment de voter la
motion de rejet la protection des
enfants passe par la volonté politique
de mettre des moyens dans l'éducation
numérique et dans l'éducation sexuelle
des adolescents or votre gouvernement ne
fait rien pour appliquer et respecter la
loi en vigueur en matière de prévention
et d'éducation sexuelle d'après une
enquête de la direction générale de
l'enseignement scolaire seulement 13,5 %
des élèves en école primaire ont
bénéficié des trois séances annuelles
d'éducation à la sexualité qui sont
pourtant prévu dans le code de
l'éducation malheureusement monsieur le
ministre vous renvoyez cela à votre
collègue qui est à l'éducation pour une
un hypothétique futur projet de loi
censé répondre à l'impérieuse nécessité
de mener une politique de prévention et
d'éducation avec ce gouvernement on a
compris une chose dès qu'il s'agit de
moyens réel nous sommes renvoyés au
calandre grec vu que de toute façon la
loi de finances passera sans en
discussion avec un
493 je disais que ce texte est un fonet
je m'explique vous prétendez sécuriser
et réguler mais ce que plusieurs
associations et collectives de défense
des droits et libertés voient dans ce
texte c'est votre intention
obsessionnelle de placer les internautes
sur surveillance généralisée au nom de
la sécurité des enfants dont on a vu
qu'il n'en est rien vous allez imposer
non seulement pour les sites porno mais
aussi pour les réseaux sociaux des
contrôles à l'entrée contrôle d'identité
pour tout le monde vos papiers s'il vous
plaît car je le dis à nos concitoyens
qui sont laissés dans l'ignorance cette
loi vise à ouvrir le chemin du contrôle
d'identité pour l'accès à Internet et au
servicees d'Internet le gouvernement
veut commencer par les plateformes porno
les jeux non monétisables mais il va
poursuivre avec les réseaux sociaux et
vous verrez que bientôt il s'attaquera
au messagerie qui devront demander aussi
une identification vous ne pourrez plus
ouvrir un compte et même posséder un
compte sans avoir au préalable donner
votre carte d'identité à une société
privée qui pour le compte d'une autre
société ou de l'État vérifiera votre âge
vérifiera que vous n'êtes pas inscrit
dans un fichier de condamneré à un
bannissement numérique ou dans un
fichier de condamné pour appel à une
manifestation non autorisée ainsi vous
serez libre d'aller sur internet à la
seulle condition de vous identifier
c'est comme pendant le covid vous êtes
libre de sortir avec autorisation Pr
préalable de sortie consentie par la
cooherition sociale si vous voulez une
vie sociale une vie citoyenne montrez
patte blanche l'État doit pouvoir tout
savoir de vous c'est de cela dont nous
parlons les politesses de la commission
spéciale n'ont pas permis de cacher la
réalité peut-être que d'autres groupes
ici estiment que ce n'est pas grave mais
pour tous les défenseurs des droits
fondamentaux et des libertés il y a
alerte sur la dérive liberticide de ces
mesures la double vérification que vous
proposez est cheval de TR du contrôle
d'identité numérique généralisé c'est
une une arnaque ce qui est cocasse pour
un gouvernement qui prétend lutter
contre les arnaques en ligne je rappelle
que le droit à l'anonymat en ligne est
consacré par le droit internationale et
la Constitution française si le
gouvernement français fait sauter ce
verrou nous nous dirigerons
inexorablement vers une société du
contrôle social à la chinoise vous
ouvrez déjà la voie à la censure des
avec votre filtre dit anti-arnaque
justement qui est prévu à l'article 6 et
qui permet à l'autorité administrative
d'exiger le blocage de certains sites
par les navigateurs évidemment en
principe cela ne doit concerner que les
sites frauduleux mais comment garantir
qu'un qu'à terme un gouvernement ne
l'utilise pas à des fins politiques en
France ou ailleurs c'est bien le
reproche que nous vous faisons dans ce
texte en voulant tout régler par la
technique vous jetez nos principes de
justice de liberté d'expression et de
démocratie aux Ortis et entre le modèle
chinois du numérique et le modèle
américain des gsfemes un autre espace
numérique est possible notre
souveraineté nationale passe aussi par
le
numérique nous avons 10 ans de retard
peut-être 15 mais c'est encore jouable à
condition de faire autrement que ce que
vous faites j'en viens à ce sujet la
celui de la souveraineté numérique car
vous l'avez beaucoup à la bouche mais
concr traitement ce projet de loi ne
permet encore rien et rien avant
longtemps le problème des règlements
européens qui sont inscrits dans ce
texte de loi et qu'ils sont limités ils
sont le fruit d'un compromis entre
beaucoup d'intérêts divergents et sous
influence des gâsfemes et des géants du
web à cela s'ajoute que la position
française est antinomique avec celle de
l'Allemagne en matière d'hébergement des
données oui dans l'idéal la stratégie
européenne pour les données devrait
permettre de mutualiser les moyens des
différents pays européens et ainsi
abaisser des barrières à l'entrée d'un
marché qui sinon restera monopolisé par
les géants américains mais regardez les
choses en face la différ les diff la
différence de vue avec l'Allemagne sur
l'indépendance numérique laisse peu de
place à une stratégie européenne
cohérente et efficace l'Allemagne fait
le choix délibérer des centres de
données américains afin d'obtenir la
garantie de pouvoir pénétrer le marché
américain difficile dans ces conditions
de développer une politique européenne
cohérente pour l'Allemagne la
souveraineté est un frein à
l'exportation de ces biens elle doit
donc nécessairement passer par une
alliance contractuelle avec les marchés
extérieurs en l'occurrence américain
pour nous notre souveraineté passe
tenez-vous bien par la planification
écologique monsieur barreot il est tant
d'intégrer dans votre logiciel de
ministre du numérique la dimension
écologique comme une dimension
fondatrice non seulement de notre
souveraineté mais aussi de notre
équilibre territorial et comme un moyen
de faire l'égalité
pour l'accessibilité de tous les
citoyens vous faites l'impasse total sur
la sobriété numérique et les enjeux
écologiques du numérique au moment où
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique va passer de 2,5 % à 7 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
France d'ici à 2030 la consommation
d'électricité va exploser dans les
années à venir et les Data cinur sont
toujours plus énergivores c'est en
pensant la dissémination des Data Center
sur l'ensemble du territoire c'est en
pensant la consommation énergétique et
l'utilisation de l'énergie produite
qu'on peut développer sur un plan
quinquénal les infrastructures
indispensables pour stocker les données
de santé les données des entreprises et
des collectivités et ainsi mettre à
l'abri cette richesse des puissances
étrangères et en même temps cette
richesse qui est un véritable talon
d'achile pour nos entreprises nos
sociétés notre pays c'est é en pensant
aussi à un Cloud souverain qui
garantisse une maîtrise globale de la
chaîne de production matérielle et
logicielle sans recours à la sraitance
malheureusement ce projet de loi va nous
mettre en retard et vous refusez même
l'idée d'une planification écologique
dotée d'un agenda d'un budget d'une
stratégie globale il en va pourtant de
notre souveraineté économique et de la
sécurité des données des collectivités
des entreprises et de nos concitoyens
j'en arrive à un dernier sujet qui
j'espère terminera de convaincre mes
collègues de voter la motion de censure
de de rejet la motion de rejet pas de
censure ça c'est pour la prochaine fois
il s'agit de l'article 15 le fameux
article sorar cet article est la preuve
s'il en manquait encore que ce projet de
loi est une fumisterie vous avez d'abord
tenté de le cacher en demandant une
habilitation à légiférer par ordonnance
puis vous essayez de nous amadouer en
nous promettant une expérimentation qui
on le sait tous ici s'éternisera ce
débat est vraiment important car
l'autorité nationale des jeux nous
alerte sur le taux de prévalence le taux
prévalence c'est le taux de joueurs
ayant une pratique jugée problématique
des jeux à objet numérique monétisable
ce taux s'élève à 20 % c'est deux fois
plus que pour les jeux d'argent
classiques il monte à 27 % dès qu'on
parle de jeux du type sorar sorar c'est
le non dit le grand tabou de cette de ce
projet de loi qui est créé en réalité
exclusivement pour cette licorne
française en déclin soyons clair sorar
propose des service à la lisière entre
jeux d'argent et paris sportif il
devrait y être assimilé au lieu de ça on
crée un véritable régime d'exception
pour une seule entreprise le droit est
précis l'article l321 du code de
sécurité intérieure indique que son
réputé jeux d'argent et de hasard et
sont et comme tel toute opération
offerte au public pour faire naître
l'espérance d'un gain qui serit du même
partiellement au hasard et pour lesquels
un sacrifice financier est exigé c'est
exactement le principe du jeu so5 de la
société sorar elle regroupe absolument
tous les critères d'un jeu d'argent et
d'ailleurs il ne s'en cachent même pas
leurs publicités disent jouer et
collectionner des cartes au format NFT
des milliers d'euros de crypto à gagner
je ne vois vraiment pas monsieur le
ministre ce qui les distingue
foncièrement deme un jeu d'argent et de
hasard si ce n'est surprise les cadeaux
fiscaux que vous vous apprêtez à leur
faire je sais que vous allez me répondre
innovation et liberté en réalité vous
déroulez le tapis rouge à ce type
d'entreprise vous voulez les favoriser
alors qu'elle vise un public jeune vous
ne pouvez pas justifier cela par la
création d'emploi c'est faux vous
vouzignorz peut-être mais la société SAR
c'est peut-être des centaines de
millions d'euros de levé mais c'est très
peu de création d'emploi peine quelques
dizaines vous leur permettez aussi et
surtout donc de bénéficier d'un régime
fiscal particulier on n'en connaît pas
les contours vous nous avez renvoyer au
PLF sauf que le PLF il n'y aura pas de
discussion puisqu'il y aura un 493 donc
on a on va vous interroger là-dessus et
j'invite tous mes collègues à s'opposer
à cet article 15 voilà j'ai exposé en
peu de temps les lignes rouges qui nous
poussent au rejet global de ce texte je
sais que de nombreux députés y compris
dans les rangs de la majorité membres de
renaiss même partage mon point de vue
nous ne sommes pas dans les caricatures
ni les oppositions de circonstances ce
texte suscite des doutes chez vous la
meilleure chose à faire quand on doute
même quand on est surtout quand on est
en charge de la loi c'est de se donner
le temps de lever les doutes le rejet du
texte et l'occasion de se remettre au
travail pour faire
mieux merci Madame la
député monsieur le ministre souz
[Applaudissements]
parole merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les les
députés en écoutant la la défense de
cette motion de rejet de la France
insoumise en réalité c'est la France
insouciante que j'avais l'impression
d'entendre insouciante vis-à-vis de la
détresse de nos concitoyens dont les
données personnelles ou les données
bancaires sont pillées tous les jours et
qui se retrouent sans solution dans la
spirale infernale de l'usurpation
d'identité ils vous écrivent mesdames et
messieurs les députés ils vous appellent
pour vous demander de trouver des
solutions la solution elle est là c'est
le filtre anti-arnaque qui préviendra le
pillage massif des données personnelles
et des données bancaires de nos
concitoyens la France insouciante
de la génération sacrifié de nos enfants
exposés à 12 ans à 11 ans à 10 ans au
contenu pornographique déversé
massivement par des sites
pornographiques irresonsabl sur Internet
la solution elle est là c'est l'article
1 et l'article 2 qui donnera à l'arcom
les pouvoirs suffisants pour dissuader
une bonne fois pour toutes les sites
pornographique de s'abstenir d'appliquer
la loi et de vérifier l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs partout et tout le temps
la France insouciante face à la détresse
des femmes harcelées sur les réseaux
sociaux qui voi constamment cell celles
et ceux qui les harcelllent se
réinscrire sur les mêmes plateformes
pour recommencer pour les harceler une
nouvelle fois la peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux vous le savez
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
sont les femmes harcelées incessamment
qui nous ont demandé de la prendre pour
faire en sorte de faire cesser la
récidive alors madame la députée vous
critiquez certaines des mesures du texte
et je commencerai par le cadre que nous
voulons créer pour les gunume les jeux à
objets numériques monétisa mesdames et
messieurs les députés c'est vrai il y a
des inquiétudes qui s'expriment mais ce
sont des jeux qui existent déjà ce sont
des jeux que nos enfants ont d'ors et
déjà pris en main alors qu'allons-nous
faire allons-nous laisser les acteurs
français cesser de développer ces
solutions et laisser entre les mains
d'enfants de nos enfants ou de personnes
sensibles ou de personnes surendetté ou
de personnes qui sont pr à l'addiction
des jeux à objets numériques
monétisables qui viennent de partout
ailleurs dans le monde ou allons-nous
créer en France un cadre responsable
pour le développement de ces activités
qui bénéficieront certes à des start-ups
qui ne manqueront pas de venir se
développer de créer des emplois en
France mais aussi à un acteur qui est
représenté dans chacune de votre
circonscription je veux parler du PMU de
ces 1000 collaborateurs des so 0000
emplois de la filière ipique et des
14000 points de vente qui cherchent
aujourd'hui évidemment des moyens de
garantir la pérennité de ces emplois
vous critiquez madame la députée
l'article 1 et l'article 2 de ce projet
de loi en vous référant à des tribunes
imprécises d'activistes un peu perdus
d'où viennent l'article 1 et l'article 2
de ce projet de loi mesdames et
messieurs les députés ils viennent d'un
rapport édifiant rédigé par des collègue
sénatrice madame Annique billon sén
centriste madame Alexandra borchot
fontim sénatrice LR madame Laurence
Cohen sénatrice communiste madame
Laurence Rossignol sénatrice PS qui
toutes disent qu'il faut donner à
l'arcom le pouvoir de bloquer ces sites
et qui disent qu'il faut que
l'arcom publie un référentiel pour que
les sites se mettent en conformité
fiez-vous mesdames et messieurs les
députés à ce que vous disent les
sénatrices qui se sont penchées sur le
sujet plutôt que à des activistes à la
dérive et puis enfin Madame la Députée
et là franchement je ne peux pas vous
laisser dire ce que vous avez dit sur
les compromis trouvés au niveau européen
il ne s'est rien passé pendant deux
décennies s'agissant des géants du
numérique qui se sont retranchés en
Irlande en profitant en profitant de
l'absence d'accords européen en
profitant de l'hétérogénéité de nos
législations européennes et il a fallu
et il a fallu et c'est vrai il faut
rendre crédit à cette majorité au
président de la République au
commissaire européen français issu du
groupe
renw toute l'énergie pour faire en sorte
de convaincre tous les pays européens
d'adopter ces deux règlements majeurs
qui vont mettre au pas pour la première
fois dans l'histoire les plateformes qui
justement échappai complètement à leur
responsabilité alors oui ce sont des
compromis mais l'europeis ce sont des
compromis l'Europe c'est une cause
imparfaite et quand on est européens
convaincus mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est l'imperfection de la cause
qui fait la force de notre engagement
c'est précisément pour rendre l'Europe
meilleure que nous nous engageons alors
nous agissons en Europe et pas à pas
nous créons les conditions pour faire en
sorte que les droits et les devoirs
soient respectés dans l'espace numérique
ce projet de loi fait partie de ces pas
progressifs qui vont nous permettre
d'obtenir gain de cause c'est la raison
pour laquelle je vous demande mesdames
et messieurs les députés de rejeter
massivement cette motion de
rejet merci monsieur le
ministre avant de vous donner la parole
monsieur le rapporteur général je vais
inviter tout le monde à s'écouter dans
le calme et monsieur le ministre vous
êtes avant tout un député à guéri je le
sais très bien et pour nous aider à
pouvoir présider plus facilement je
rappelle à tout le monde qu'il est
interdit de brandir quoi que ce soit
dans cet hémicycle et voilà
je vous remercie parce que après ça va
être compliqué pour
nous mais je je non mais s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît tout le monde Je je
précise gentiment au
ministres qui vient de crier quoi
là
vous non et et je précise gentiment pour
que ça n'arrive plus on ne brandit rien
et je l'ai dit gentiment
et dans la joie et la bonne humeur
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez la
parole alors s'il vous plaît je viens
dire je viens demander à tout le monde
de s'écouter s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît monsieur monsieur le rapporteur et
seul monsieur le rapporteur général a la
parole merci madame la Présidente alors
chers collègues sur cette motion de
rejet moi je vous cite cinq chiffres
très simple
50 % 50 % c'est la part de nos jeunes
qui ont dit avoir été cyberharcelés sur
internet
15 15 jours c'est le nombre de jours
qu'il y a entre chaque suicide de nos
jeunes dans ce pays après
cyberharcèlement ou harcèlement
scolaire
50 % à nouveau 50 % c'est la part des
arnaques en ligne aujourd'hui dans notre
pays
9 millions 9 millions ce sont le nombre
de Français qui se font arnaquer en
ligne chaque année qui perdent de
l'argent dans ses arnaques en
ligne et 80 % ça sera le dernier chiffre
80 % ce sont la part des enfants qui
dans notre pays ont été exposés à la
pornographie à cause d'Internet parfois
très jeune cette situation elle n'est
pas acceptable nous devons agir ce texte
il nous permet d'agir sur cette
situation là et donc je pense que ne pas
voter ce texte ça serait une erreur mais
ne même pas le débattre serait une faute
politique merci merci monsieur le
rapporteur général nous en venons aux
explications de vote monsieur Aurélien
taché merci madame la Présidente bon on
a eu l'occasion en commission d'échangé
avec Monsieur le Ministre avec monsieur
le rapporteur général et l'ensemble des
collègues et j'ai trouvé moi aussi cette
commission assez constructive euh vous
le savez les écologistes sont favorable
à un certain nombre de mesures que
contient ce texte la transposition du
DSA ne nous pose aucun problème d'autres
objectifs sont aussi des objectifs que
l'on partage lutter contre le
cyberhcèlement vous venez de le rappeler
monsieur le rapporteur général la
protection des mineurs face à
l'exposition des films pornographiques
est aussi un objectif que l'on partage
mais si on prend un peu point par point
le début du dispositif du texte est
consacré à ce point de la section des
mineurs contre finalement les les les
films pornographiques bon est-ce que
véritablement avec le texte aujourd'hui
on arrivera à faire peser sur
l'industrie pornographique la
responsabilité qui est laaleure je ne le
crois malheureusement pas est-ce qu'on
arrivera à protéger aussi les acteurs
les actrices d'un certain nombre de
pratiques qui peuvent être absolument
déplorables et illégales le au Conseil
l'égalité a l'air de penser que non
est-ce qu'on va réussir à protéger nos
enfants de l'exposition je n'en suis pas
totalement certain parce que le système
que vous proposez finalement c'est soit
de mettre la carte bancaire les enfants
peuvent la la prendre aux parents soit
un espèce de système de double anonymat
qu'on a pas encore très très bien
compris et ce qu'on a bien compris par
contre c'est que l'arcom l'Autorité de
régulation administrative en charge de
ces questions et qui n'est pas la
justice hein qui n'est pas totalement
indépendante elle va pouvoir contrôler
l'identité des uns et des autres et ça
c'est quand même un gros point
d'inquiétude c'est un gros point
d'inquiétude monsieur le rapporteur
général parce qu'en plus vous avez quand
même fait un certain nombre de
propositions au cours au fur et à mesure
des débats pour nous démontrer que
finalement vous souhaitiezv mettre en
place un système d'immatriculation
numérique un système finalement un peu
de contrôle de l'identité numérique par
l'État donc tout ça me semble un petit
peu un petit peu flou et et donc à ce
stade je ne suis pas tellement convaincu
par le dispositif si on reprend un autre
sujet qui vient d'être exposé par ma
collègue sopia Chikirou par exemple les
les les fameux jeonumes les les les jeux
numéques à objet à objet monétisable euh
bon tout le monde nous a dit l'Autorité
de Régulation des Jeux les autorités
qu'on a pu consulter que il s'agissait
visiblement de casino en ligne déguisé
et est ce que vous nous proposez à ce
stade c'est une expérimentation qui
finalement donnerait un cadre un peu
plus souple un peu plus dérogatoire que
ce que connaissent aujourd'hui les jeux
d'argent et moi je l'ai déjà dit pendant
pendant les débats je suis frappé chaque
jour de voir combien ces familles ces
jeunes dans les quartiers populaires
peuvent être finalement merci conclure
chers
cègues en fait je vais vous dire
simplement ce que je pense
merci la parole est éor merci la parole
est à Monsieur Christophe nelen pour le
groupe
lot merci madameci merci madame la
Présidente en fin de compte sur ce texte
nous serons sans doute pas d'accord sur
tout nous allons proposer un un certain
nombre d'amendements visant à
l'améliorer mais la réalité aussi c'est
qu'il va plutôt dans le bon sens et dans
ce qu'est actuellement la jungle
internet on a besoin d'avoir une
régulation plus forte une régulation ce
n'est pas une interdiction des libertés
c'est juste lorsque des choses illégales
sont faites que nous soyons en capacité
de la sanctionné de plus on sait très
bien que nous sommes en nécessité
d'avoir ces transpositions européennes
sur le Data Act et autres donc c'est
pour ces différentes raisons et en plus
par principe nous votons contre les
motion de rejet parce que nous partons
du principe que c'est dans cet hémicycle
que doit se faire la loi et que nous
devons discuter que nous voterons contre
cette motion de
rejet merci Monsieur nagelen Madame
Marie gevennou merci madame la
Présidente vous avez raison Madame
Chikirou d'avoir noté l'atmosphère
respectueuse qui avait prévalu à nos
débats aux commissions c'était som toute
effectivement assez agréable et
constructif et au fond ce serait bien
que ça continue et ce serait bien que
les interventions de la France insommise
ne servent pas à discrédité tout à la
fois le projet de loi le ministre le
travail des sénatrices même jusqu'à des
entreprises au fond que vous jetez ici
en anathème dans cet hémicycle ce serait
bien que oui on retrouve une atmosphère
respectueuse moi ma conviction en vous
écoutant madame Chikirou c'est que vous
n'avez ni envie de sécuriser ni envie de
réguler le numérique vous n'avez pas
envie de réguler ces espaces vous
considérez que 9 millions de victimes
d'arnaque c'est finalement pas un sujet
vous considérez que 50 % de jeunes
cyberhcelés ce n'est pas un sujet vous
considérez que des garçons de 12 ans
notre pays la moitié des garçons 12 ans
dans le pays qui sont exposés à un
contenu pornographique ce n'est pas un
sujet et ben vous pensez que c'est pas
un sujet et ben nous nous pensons le
contraire et nous rejetterons votre
motion très bien merci
madame la députée je vous informe que
sur le vote de la motion de rejet je
suis saisie par le groupe la France
insoumise nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale d'une demande de
scrutin public le scutin est annoncé
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
la parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Lopez
ligori alors merci madame la Présidente
nous examinons la motion de rejet de la
France insoumise donc sur ce projet de
loi numérique alors nous partageons les
inquiétudes de nos collègues traçage
étendu à tous les usagers par les
réseaux sociaux avec l'article 5
généralisation de l'identité numérique
avec l'article 4 AC de manière générale
en fait des menaces sur notre vie privée
et notre liberté d'expression donc vous
piétinez nos droits et tombez dans une
dérive qu'on pourrait dire presque
autoritaire mais l'enfer est pavé de
bonne intention vous pensez peut-être
bien faire mais votre projet est pas de
plus vers une société de surveillance
mais ce projet de loi c'est aussi une
opportunité pour nous d'adopter des
règles protectrices pour les
utilisateurs et pour nos entreprises
protectrice des utilisateurs avec le
filtre anti-arnaque le retrait des
contenus pédopornographiques ou les
obligations de transparence des sites
internet protectrices de nos entreprises
avec l'encadrement des crédits Cloud et
les obligations d'interopérabilité euh
et de portabilité des fournisseurs cloud
alors nous voulons aller au débat nous
voulons voter pour des mesures qui vont
dans le bon sens dans ce texte et nous
voulons avoir l'occasion de nous battre
contre les mesures scandaleuse qu'il
contient alors le la LFI a ce réflexe de
déposer systématiquement une motion de
rejet sur chaque texte mais vu l'enjeu
crucial que représente le numérique au
21e siècle il me paraît pas anormal
d'avoir au moins que ce soit une bonne
idée d'au moins avoir un débat au
rassemblé nationale nous pensons qu'il
faut ce débat nous voterons donc contre
cette motion de rejet mais ce n'est pas
un blancin que que nous donnons au
gouvernement nous nous réservons notre
position de vote en fonction de
l'évolution de ce texte et nous serons
particulièrement attentifs à l'article 5
et aux amendements du rapporteur Paul
midi
merci
merci la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-François
coulom madame la madame la Présidente
chers collègues monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre voilà déjà
plusieurs semaines que nous travaillons
sur ce texte et il faut bien avouer que
nous restons sur notre fin bien
évidemment nous nous accordons sur
l'importance de traiter des sujets tels
que l'accès au mineurs à la pornographie
la protection des citoyens et citoyennes
contre le cyberharcellement et encore
l'encadrement et la prévention des
arnaques sur internet mais votre texte
se penche aussi sur la concurrence et la
souveraineté au sein de l'informatique
en nuage l'expérimentation de jeux
monétisables les plateformes de tourisme
en location ou encore le traitement des
données personnels dans les juridictions
vaste sujet qui tous mérite bien plus
qu'un texte baclé dont l'illisibilité le
rend difficile à appréhender proposer
des textes confus et Fourtout vous
permettent ainsi d'y glisser des mesures
liberticides à titre soi-disant
expérimental nous tentons de voir plus
loin que ces expérimentations qui se
glisse dans ce projet de loi car votre
texte propose en réalité de nouvelles
atteintes aux libertés fondamentales
camouflé derrière des réalités cruelles
et intolérables en l'état votre texte
n'offre aucune solution réelle de
protection des cito citoyenes et des
citoyens mineurs comme majeur sur
Internet la question épineuse de ce
projet est finalement de savoir ce que
nous sommes disposés à sacrifier
collectivement comme liberté et surtout
de voir jusqu'où ces dérives nous
conduirons sur le long terme ce projet
de loi comporte les prémisses de la fin
de l'anonymma en ligne et du droit à la
vie privée avec des déclarations du
rapporteur général sur une extension
d'un recours à l'identité numérique à ce
stade non solutionné ce texte illustre
le renoncement du gouvernement à
débattre profondément sur des sujets
impactant la vie des Françaises et des
Français la question du numérique et de
sa sécurité de sa régulation ne sont
même pas au cœur du texte c'est pour ces
raisons que nous voterons la motion de
rejet que dépose notre groupe la France
insoumise nous pensons intimement que
chacun des sujets abordés dans ce texte
mérite une réflexion accrue et nous nous
tenons à votre disposition pour élaborer
ensemble une stratégie pérenne et
respectueuse des libertés individuelles
et collectives merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Monsieur Victor Abert
d'assau merci madame la Présidente nom
des républicains nous pensons que nous
abordons aujourd'hui une question
essentielle la régulation du numérique
cruciale pour notre avenir et notre
souveraineté de nombreux sujets variés
doivent impérativement faire l'objet
d'une nouvelle législation voter cette
motion reviendrait à considérer que ces
enjeux et les débats affiliés n'ont pas
leur place dans notre législation
nationale nous sommes un carrefour
digital et face à des décisions qui
influenceront l'avenir de notre pays
nous pensons par conséquent qu'il faut
avoir un débat et nousous opposerons à
la motion de rejet merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
eskenet
gox merci madame la Présidente le groupe
démocrate s'opposera bien évidemment à
cette motion de rejet le débat que nous
ouvrons aujourd'hui est essentiel pour
de nombreuses raisons les règlements DSA
et DMA sont des avancées majeures
obtenues par la France lors de la
présidence du Conseil de l'Union
européenne au premier semestre 2022 mais
au-delà des avancées européennes
essentielles pour lesquelles nous devons
adapter notre droit ce texte est
l'occasion d'aller encore plus loin sur
de nombreux sujets nous souhaitons tous
avancer pour la protection de nos
enfants leur exposition à des contenus
pornographiques n'a que trop duré depuis
trop d'années les plateformes ignorent
le droit malgré les injenctions de
l'arcom les plaines des associations et
les rappels à l'ordre grâce à ce texte
grâce au référentiel nous pouvons aller
plus loin et plus vite pour faire en
sorte que C respectent enfin leurs
obligations participant à rendre le net
plus sûr pour nos enfants je voudrais
saluer ici le travail du ministre du
rapporteur général ainsi que de
l'ensemble des rapporteurs thématiques
avec une intention appuyée pour le
travail effectué sur la première partie
du texte car au-delà de la protection
des mineurs c'est tout un arsenal de
lutte contre le harcèlement et la haine
en ligne qui est proposé avec la peine
complémentaire de blocage les sanctions
pour les deep fake ou encore les amendes
pour outrage sexiste bien sûr le projet
de loi pourra être encore enrichi bien
sûr certaines dispositions pourront être
revues je sais que sur les sujets
abordés par ce texte nous pourrons
battir des consensus et les les
démocrates participeront à les battir
que ce soit sur la médiation en ligne
que je porte la lutte contre la sex
torion ou le renforcement de la
régulation des influenceurs mais tout
cela ne sera pas possible sans un vrai
débat parlementaire chers collègues je
vous invite tous à y participer je vous
remercie merci monsieur le député la
parole est à Monsieur Hervé
souignac merci Madame la la présidente
cette motion de rejet a au moins le
mérite monsieur le ministre de vous
faire entrer avec vigueur pour ne pas
dire ferveur dans le dans le débat
euh sur le sur le fond je ne reviendrai
pas sur la primauté du droit européen
qui n'est pas un détail pour nous et
donc l'obligation d'adapter notre notre
droit euh ce texte est-il un peu
Fourtout comme l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure notre collègue Chikirou oui mais
c'est pas le premier certainement pas le
le dernier et ça ne nous semble pas
justifié en soit un rejet ce texte
répond-t-il à tout non et un certain
nombre de questions n'ont pas été abordé
la question de l'éducation numérique est
centrale celle des jeux illégaux n'est
pas traité la question écologique est
aussi relativement passé sous silence la
question du cloud souverain paraît être
mise de côté mais si ce texte est
Fourtout euh comment est-il possible
d'en rajouter un peu plus alors nous
pensons que ce texte soulève surtout des
sujets graves des sujets
particulièrement sérieux la protection
de l'enfance la lutte contre la
pédopornographie le cyberhcèlement
l'encadrement des des fournisseurs de
Cloud et pour toutes ces raisons nous
pensons que ces sujets doivent être
débattu si nous avons du retard sur un
certain nombre de domaines n'en prenons
peut-être pas plus et c'est en
conscience que nous ne voterons pas
cette motion de rejet merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame agè Carel
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues à travers cette motion de
rejet préalable le groupe de la France
insoumise à le mérite de la cohérence il
ne dévie pas de sa ligne s'opposer à
tout et sur tous les sujets tout le
temps et sans débat bien sûr
conformément à leur attachement profond
à la
démocratie d'abord vous dire ma
déception profonde les débats en
commission sur ce texte ambitieux et
nécessaire ont été passionnés et
passionnants enrichissant pour tous et
surtout respectueux des opinions de
chacun je sais le travail acharné des
rapporteurs de ce texte pour chercher le
consensus entre les différents groupes
de cette assemblée alors voilà je
déplore la forme mais plus encore je
désespère du fond quoi que vous en dites
à travers cette motion de rejet
préalable vous souhaitez rejeter d'un
coup d'un seul l'ensemble de ce texte
vous qui prétendez être si attaché à la
protection des mineurs vous qui
prétendez être si attaché à la lutte
contre les violences sexuelles et
sexistes vous qui prétendez être pour
une régulation stricte des acteurs
économiques vous nous proposez
aujourd'hui de rejeter l'idée même d'un
meilleur contrôle de l'accès des mineurs
à la pornographie vous nous proposez de
rejeter l'idée d'un bannissement des
réseaux sociaux des cyberharceleurs qui
détruisent la vie de tant de personnes
vous nous proposez de rejeter l'idée
d'une protection de nos concitoyens face
aux actes de cyber malveillance de
rejeter l'idée d'une meilleure
régulation des acteurs étrangers du
cloud qui écrasent aujourd'hui le marché
européen votre cohérence s'arrête donc à
votre propos à votre opposition
systématique et c'est là où commence
l'action de tous les députés qui veulent
agir pour protéger nos concitoyens dont
nous faisons partie le groupe horizon et
apparenté votera contre cette motion de
rejet merci madame la Présidente merci
madame la
députée nous allons maintenant procéder
au scrutin je vais donc mettre au voix
la motion de rejet je vous prie de bien
vouloir regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
206 exprimés 204 majorité 103 pour 32
contre 172 l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
adopté nous en venons à la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur
Aurélien tacher pour le groupe
écologiste
[Applaudissements]
nupès
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
chers collègues on va rentrer un petit
peu plus dans dans le détail de ce que
je voulais vous dire sur ce texte
puisque je n'ai pas pu le faire vos
explications de vote et c'est bien
normal j'étais trop long madame la
Présidente lorsqu'on propose une loi on
doit d'abord regarder ce qu'elle peut
apporter mais aussi on doit regarder ce
qu'elle peut enlever à nos concitoyens
c'est cet équilibre là finalement qu'on
doit toujours étudier et aussi je le
disais tout à l'heure ce projet de loi
sur le numérique et plein de bonnes
intentions même parfois de bonnes idé
quand il s'agit de de par exemple
transposer le DSA ou pour les objectifs
protéger nos enfants ou lutter contre le
cybber harcèlement nous pensons qu'en
l'état il met aussi malheureusement un
certain nombre de liberté numérique en
danger c'est de ça dont je voudrais vous
parler vous souhaitez chers collègues de
la majorité que le numérique ressemble
au réel mais moi je veux que ce qui est
aujourd'hui un des derniers espaces de
liberté soit soumis ne soit pas soumis à
des contrôles injustifiés au nom de la
sécurité le projet de loi qui arrive
aujourd'hui dans notre assemblée risque
pourtant si on y prend pas garde de
renforcer cette logique de société de
surveillance cette société de du
contrôle permanent et de faire reculer
ces précieuses libertés vous voulez par
exemple mettre fin à l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie on est
évidemment d'accord sur cet objectif
loin des jugements moraux ou d'un
quelconque puritanisme il s'agit
d'éviter qu'une majorité d'enfants ne
découvrent la sexualité à travers des
pratiques souvent bien éloignées de la
réalité parfois extrême et même illégal
qu'il risque de reproduire ensuite mais
c'est d'abord par l'éducation et la
prévention ou en renforçant les
possibilités de contrôle donné au
parents que nous devons atteindre cette
ambition ainsi qu'en faisant peser la
responsabilité de la régulation sur
l'industrie pornographique elle-même et
non sur l'administration car le système
que vous nous proposez repose sur une
logique de surveillance et d'exclusion
en donnant à l'arcom le pouvoir de
contrôler l'identité des utilisateurs et
de fermer directement des sites qui
contreviennent à leurs obligations vous
vous allez finalement mettre deux
risques en en exergue un d'abord de
censure du web car ça devrait être à la
justice indépendante de procéder à ces
fermetures euh l'extension de ce
principe pourrait en effet conduire
demain en étant dans l'émission de
l'arcom àce qu'elle puisse fermer tout
site qui ne convient pas au gouvernement
et je crois que c'est inutile de de
démontrer pourquoi la démocratie et les
libertés se trouveraient menacé la
tentation qu'il a eu par exemple à un
moment de mettre dans ce texte et je
vous salue monsieur le ministre de ne
pas l'avoir fait de couper les réseaux
sociaux et messageries dans certaines
situations démontre que cette tentation
est bien présente vous ouvrez aussi une
brèche dangereuse sur la protection de
l'anonymat pour l'instant elle serait
limitée au site pornographique mais on
voit bien à travers vos propositions mon
cher collègue Paul midi que ça ne
pourrait être qu'une première étape or
le respect de l'anonymat sur internet ça
doit rester une ligne rouge c'est ce qui
permet à des journalistes
d'investigation à des lanceurs d'alerte
de travailler sereinement et de nous
fournir certaines informations dont nous
avons besoin en tant que citoyen comment
serons-nous informés demain sur des
sujets internationaux de corruption
d'abus des autorités sans garantir les
finalements anonymes alors que les États
généraux de l'information démarré hier
et que la journaliste Arianne lavriux
était arrêtée la semaine dernière soyons
vigilants et refusons une société O où
le droit à la vie privée et la liberté
d'expression ne seraiit plus vraiment
protégé c'est le même danger que
pourrait entraîner la généralisation de
de l'identité numérique ou le blocage
direct des sites web par l'État à
travers le filtre anti-arnaque que vous
aviez initialement imaginé il est vrai
nous l'avons déjà dit que la lutte
contre les arnaques notamment à travers
les influenceurs doit devenir une
priorité mais cela ne peut se faire au
détriment des libertés numériques et en
faisant peser sur les navigateurs des
obligations démesurées n'oublions pas
que la gouvernance d'Internet repose sur
un consortium mondial et que si demain
la France les oblige à fermer eux-mêmes
certains sites les régimes autor qui
jusqu'ici n'avaent jamais rien demandé
ne se priveront pas eux aussi de de de
demander cela au navigateurs et ce ne
seront pas seulement les sites d'arnaque
qui seront visés nous le savons vous et
moi la protection de nos données la
souveraineté numérique sont essentiels
mais pas au prix de nos libertés et pour
vraiment sécuriser l'espace numérique
c'est surtout à ces géants du numérique
que sont les gfames que vous auriez dû
vous attaquer notamment au quasi
monopole dont ils disposent pour stocker
nos données mais ça ne vous dérange pas
que ces gigantesques entreprise qui
échappe déjà pour beaucoup à
l'imposition et qui crée une concurrence
déloyale sur le monde de la technologie
française puiss avoir aut aant accès à
autant d'information sur la population
qu'elle stock dans des serveurs à
l'étranger en cas de problème vous ferez
comme d'habitude vous demanderez un
effort un geste bref vous demanderez à
Bruno Le Maire de demander plutôt que de
vous fier à la loi plutôt que de
contraindre ces géants à respecter des
normes simples que d'autres entreprises
en France respectent déjà nous devrions
par exemple obliger les entreprises qui
travaillent avec le ministère de la
Défense celui des Affaires étrangères et
dans tous les secteurs stratégiques de
stocker leurs données en Europe les
usalgers veulent plus de sécurité pour
leur donner et leurs échanges c'est
aussi pour cela que nous vous proposons
de consacrer le droit à communiquer à
travers des messageries crypté enfin je
vais vous parler de ces fameux jeunumes
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure ce sont
des jeux qui finalement s'apparentent
plus à des jeux d'argent qu'à des jeux
vidéo des jeux où des jeunes sur ruines
ou des familles sans dett non on ne
parle pas là de simple jeux où on achète
un item pour être plus à l'aise on parle
de dizaines de milliers d'euros qui sont
finalement sous forme de cryptomonnaie
échangé nous ne voulons pas de
dérogation ou de de réglementation
spécifique pour ces jeux nous voulons ce
qui s'applique aux jeu d'argent à savoir
les mineurs doivent être absolument
protégés et une une législation ferme
doit s appppliquer vous l'avez compris
il y a effectivement des mesures
intéressantes dans votre texte mais il
manque d'ambition pour protéger nos
concitoyens pour véritablement protéger
leur liberté numérique et nous tenterons
donc tout au cours des débats
d'améliorer le texte j'espère que nous y
arriverons ensemble mais ça n'est pas
encore tout à fait gagné merci merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Madame Soumia
bouroua pour le groupe Gauche démocrate
et républicaine
nupes
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission spécial
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues légiférer en matière de
numérique est désormais une habitude
pour notre assemblée nous pourrions
regretter cette inflation normative dans
le domaine centre bien souvent aux
directives et règlements européens
parfois en cours de discussion mais les
enjeux sont si vastes les défis si
nombreux la technologie si rapide qu'il
n'y a rien d'abérrant à remettre
régulièrement sur l'ouvrage notre
législation en matière de régulation du
numérique
cependant cela ne doit pas conduire à la
précipitation tant les lignes de crête
que nous avons à emprunter sont
délicate si les députés du groupe GDR
nupes partagent bien évidemment la
nécessité de protéger nos concitoyens
dans l'espace numérique il considèrent
que cette ambition mérite un examen
serein et approfondi or ce projet de loi
très dense qui embrasse de nombreuses
branches du du droit nous est présenté
en urgence dans des délis
particulièrement serrés le Conseil
d'État a d'ailleurs alerté dans son avis
sur les circonstances problématiques
d'examen de ce texte qui ne sont pas de
nature à permettre de garantir
pleinement la sécurité juridique de ce
projet de loi en alternant des sujets
aussi variés que la pédopornographie les
jeux à objet numérique monétisable en
passant par le les clouds et la
protection des consommateurs ce texte
peine a donné un cap clair le premier
enjeu de ce texte est l'articulation du
principe et d'égale valeur la protection
des enfants et des adolescents sur
Internet est un impératif mais doit se
concilier avec le droit de la vie privé
en matière de pornographie nous nous
inscrivons pleinement dans la volonté du
gouvernement de restreindre réellement
l'accès aux mineurs et de faire
appliquer
enfin l'interdiction d'accès nous savons
toutes et tous les dégâts que cela fait
sur les plus jeunes exposés aux
pratiques les plus violentes sexiste
raciste quelle représentation des femmes
du corps de l'autre cela entraîne
comment ne pas lutter contre une
industrie où le viol est constamment
présent le rapport de la délégation des
droits des femmes porno l'enfer du décor
du Sénat nous a servi de base de travail
pour ce texte et je m'en félicite nous
soutiendrons l'ensemble des mesures qui
en sont issues
cependant cette vérification de l'âge
doit comporter des garanties importante
en matière de droit à la vie privée les
éditeurs ne doivent pas posséder les
données des utilisateurs nous plaidons
pour une technologie en double anonymat
par un tiers de confiance nous ne
pouvons vérifier l'âge à n'importe quel
prix je souhaite également alerter sur
l'article 3 qui contourne des mots même
du ministre le juge judiciaire
l'alignement sur le régime
antiterroriste avec des retraits de
contenu dans des délais est extrêmement
court et dans les mains des autorités
administratives ne nous apparaît pas la
réponse adaptée à force de contourner la
justice nous affaiblissons petit à petit
l'État de droit cette même difficulté
apparaît à l'article 6 là encore si nous
ne pouvons que partager l'objectif
contre les arnaques en ligne nous
refitons nous réfutons la possibilité
pour une autorité administrative
d'imposer le blocage de l'accès à un
service de communication au public en
ligne en raison des risques importants
pour l'exercice des libertés
individuelles le blocage de site ne
devrait être autorisé que par un juge
judiciaire afin de vérifier que la
demande n'est ni horonnée ni abusive au
regard des libertés
fondamental par ailleurs nous sommes
opposés à l'extension des amendes de
l'amende forfaitaire d'lectuelle à
certain infraction du droit de la presse
commis en ligne nous rappelons que la
procédure d'amende forfaitataire qui
permet de prononcer une sanction pénale
en l'absence de procès déroge à
plusieurs principes du droit pénal et de
la procédure pénale tel que le droit au
respect à la présomption d'innocence le
principe du contradictoire et les droits
de la défense le principe
d'individualisation des peines et enfin
le droit d'accès aux
juges de même nous nous opposons à
l'expérimentation concernant les jeunes
honnes nous ouvrons une brèche
importante dans l'interdiction sauf
dérogation des jeux d'argent et de
hasard il est pourtant estimé à 1,4
million de joueurs à risque 400000 à un
niveau pathologique dans notre pays il y
a un enjeu véritablement de santé
publique qui est totalement absent de ce
texte aussi si ce texte offre des
réponse pertinente à des sujets cruciaux
pour la protection des usagers
d'Internet nous regrettons un test un
texte trop vaste présenté dans la
précipitation qui autorise le
contournement du juge judiciaire sur
plusieurs articles au profit de
l'autorité conclure chers collègues j'ai
pas fini ah oui mais vous avez déjà
dépassé de 20 secondes yes merci chers
cèg je vous remercie j'aurais pas
pu je tiens à préciser qu'il n'y a rien
de pire pour une présidente que de
couper la parole à un collègue quel que
soit le collègue
d'ailleurs la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe nagelen pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre M et
territoire
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
internet a été créé avec un idéal celui
d'un monde où la libre circulation de
l'information favoriserait la liberté
d'expression la diffusion des
connaissances la création en fin de
compte l'innovation aujourd'hui cette
utopie menace de virer à laasisan
l'Espace Numérique est devenu celui de
la concentration des entreprises de la
polarisation politiqu et des
comportements répréhensibles pour
qu'Internet reste un lieu de liberté où
chacun puisse se sentir en sécurité et
où la concurrence recommence à s'exercer
il est nécessaire de réguler cette
régulation nous le savons doit
prioritairement se faire à l'échelle
européenne puisque c'est là où elle sera
le plus efficace c'est d'ailleurs
l'objet des quatre règlements adoptés
entre 2022 et 2023 DSA DMA des ga et
data Act notre groupe se montre bien
entendu favorable à la aux mesures de
transposition de ces directives
nécessaire pour adapter notre droit à ce
nouveau cadre de
régulation nous devons aussi à l'échelle
nationale cette fois-ci nous montrer
plus protecteur vis-à-vis des
internautes les plus fragiles c'est
notamment l'objet des titres 1 et 2
concernant les mineurs qui sont
massivement exposés au contenu
pornographique sur le net confier à
l'arcom le soin de mettre en place un un
référentiel va dans le bon sens de même
que la solution qui nous a été présenté
par le gouvernement de double anonymat
il reste qu'il faudra élargir son usage
à d'autres applications que la
pornographie pour qu'il y ait un réel
anonymat des
internautes protéger nos concitoyens
dans l'environnement numérique c'est
aussi bâtir un cadre juridique adapté
aux nouveaux usages du net
nous nous soutenons donc bien évidemment
l'interdiction de la diffusion desdep
fake sans le con sans le consentement de
la personne représentée mais nous
pensons qu'il faut aller plus loin nous
proposerons d'ailleurs de créer un
nouveau délit sanctionnant les
extorsions nous ne pouvons plus accepter
que certains utilisent des photos
intimes pour faire du chantage en ligne
de même nous sommes favorables à la
possibilité de sanctionner les injures
et les diffamations en ligne par une
amende forfaitaire pourquoi ne pas
étendre aussi cette possibilité au
messagees incitant à la haine et à la
violence en ligne gageons que cela
désincitera ceux qui se cachent derrière
leur écran nous sommes par contre un peu
plus dubitaatif quant à l'effectivité de
la peine complémentaire du blocage du
compte d'accès aux plateformes en ligne
d'une personne condamnée lorsque ce
compte a été utilisé pour commettre un
délit simple un problème technique cette
solution est aisément contournable
difficile de vérifier que la D personne
ne change pas de VPN pour poursuivre ses
activités sur le réseau concernant le
marché de l'informatique en nuage dit
cloud aujourd'hui fortement concentré
autour de quelques acteurs américains il
est urgent de mettre fin aux barrières à
l'entrée et à la sortie nous appelons
donc à Inter les frais de transfert de
données ainsi que les pratiques
d'autopréférence et de
discrimination il nous faut sur ce
marché renforcé le souveraineté
nationale j'ai entendu l'explication les
explications de la rapporteur leant et
ce sera l'occasion d'en discuter plus en
amant dans dans ce texte mais dans
l'attente nous avons déposé un
amendement pour rétablir l'article 10
bis qui impose aux opérateurs de Clad de
prendre des mesures techniques et
opérationnel pour empêcher l'accès d'un
État tiers à des données sensibles
s'agissant des objets des jeux à objets
numérique monétisable dijonum nous
reconnaissons leur spécificité néanmoins
citez-moi un autre exemple de quelque
chose que nous achetons à instanté et
qui du fait euh de du cours de l'action
de ce qu'il représente varie c'est
exactement ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en bourse avec des actions et c'est pour
pourquoi nous demandons à ce que dans le
cadre des genunumes il y ait une
taxation au niveau de la FL taxe de
plus-value réaliser lorsque il y a vente
d'un jeunum nous sommes à michement
entre le jeu vidéo le jeu d'argent et le
jeu de hasard mais nous sommes
exactement dans la même situation que ce
que peut l'être une action boursière il
faut impérativement clarifier cela c'est
pour ça avec pragmatisme et réalisme
nous défendrons nos propositions pour un
Internet mieux encadré mais toujours
espace de
liberté merci Monsieur nagelen 5 minutes
pile madame Marie gevenou pour le groupe
[Applaudissements]
Renaissance madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de la commission
spéciale monsieur le rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
spéciaux monsieur le ministre chers
collègues la possibilité qui nous est
donné avec ce projet de loi est une
vraie chance elle nous permet de venir
d'une part transposer trois règlements
européens dont l'adoption à l'initiative
de ce gouvernement et cette majorité a
été un des marqueurs de la présidence de
l'Union européenne elle permet d'autre
part de combler certaines lacunes
actuelles de notre dispositif de
protection des citoyens en ligne dont
les failles se sont dramatiquement
révélés ces derniers temps après
l'adoption de ces trois règlements qui
constituent un véritable progrès en
terme de protection pour les citoyens
comme pour les acteurs du numérique la
France peut continuer d'être précurseur
en la matière pour favoriser
l'indépendance de nos entreprises
nationales renforcer l'attractivité de
l'offre clou à la à la française et
permettre aux entreprises de se saisir
pleinement des opportunités économiques
offertes par le numérique en ce qui
concerne la protection des citoyens
l'enjeu politique premier de ce texte
est de construire un nouveau continuum
de sécurité entre les espaces physiques
et les espaces numériques pour que
cessent les zones de non droit le
sentiment d'impunité et les
comportements parfois ignobles qui ont
libre cours en cela nous nous inscrivons
aussi à la suite du travail législatif
entamé de longues dates par notre
majorité dès 2020 notre groupe avait
adopté une loi qui donnait le pouvoir à
l'arcom de lutter contre l'accès de nos
enfants au sites pornographiques depuis
ces mêmes sites pornographique ont mis
toutes leurs force pour contourner les
obligations mises en place par le
législateur face à cette inertie et sans
craindre la bataille judiciaire qui nous
intentrons nous devons aller plus loin
pour garantir partout la protection de
nos enfants aujourd'hui nous nous fixons
comme objectif la mise en place rapide
d'un référentiel ambitieux et efficace
qui permettra à l'avenir de réellement
contrôler que les utilisateurs sont
majeurs c'est aussi avec ce principe de
double anonymat qui repose sur un/ers
que nous voulons atteindre efficacement
ces objectifs de protection des mineurs
et de la vie privée dans ce but notre
commission a adopté le doublement de la
peine encourue par les éditeurs de sites
pornographiqu qui contreviendrait à
l'obligation de vérification de l'âge le
groupe Renaissance souhaite également
poursuivre son action pour un espace
numérique plus responsable et plus
protecteur nous souhaitons que comme en
commission le débat sur le sur
l'anonymat puisse aussi se tenir en
séance si chacun sait aujourd'hui dans
cette assemblée que personne n'est
anonyme sur le net la plupart des
Français eux l'ignore la mise en place
d'une identité numérique permettant
l'authentification des usagers et la
levée de l'anominima et en aucun cas la
suppression du pseudonymat nous
permettrait d'affirmer avec puissance
que personne nulle part ne peut agir en
toute
impunité dans le prolongement de ce
débat les derniers événements
dramatiques nous obligent à agir de
manière résolue contre le harcèlement
dans la continuité du plan
interministériel ambitieux de lutte
contre le cyberhcèlement qui a été
présenté la semaine dernière par la
première ministre ellisabeth borne nous
proposerons d'introduire dans notre
texte les dispositifs issus de ce plan
je tiens en effet à saluer le travail
réalisé en commission qui a permis
d'enrichir le texte initial en créant un
volet fort de sensibilisation au cœur de
la protection numérique de nos enfants
mais également de la responsabilisation
des parents nous proposerons donc en ce
s la systématisation de la certification
pix ainsi que l'introduction d'un
mécanisme permettant d'avertir les
détenteur de l'autorité parentale dont
les enfants seraient responsables de
cyberhcèlement toujours dans l'objectif
de mieux protéger les mineurs nous
proposerons que les sites de jeu à objet
numérique monétisable soient eux aussi
soumis à une obligation de vérification
d'âge enfin nous voulons donner aux
forces de l'ordre et à notre justice les
moyens d'agir plus rapidement quand les
réseaux sociaux servent à appeler à des
actions de destruction comme cela a été
le cas lors des épisodes de violence
urbaines au début de l'été
responsabiliser les acteurs des
plateformes aux utilisateurs protéger
les citoyens les plus vulnérables
sanctionner ceux qui ne respecteront pas
les règles voilà ce qui guide notre
action l'objectif de ce texte est bien
de permettre une prise de conscience
collective sur les dangers et les
nuisances dont dont l'espace numérique
est par fois le théâtre pour que demain
nous puissions y diffuser la
tranquillité et la sécurité qui s'impose
notamment pour nos enfants je vous
remerci merci Madame la première
kesteur la parole est à Monsieur Aurélie
Lopez ligori pour le groupe
rassemblement
[Applaudissements]
national
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues les élus de la
minorité présidentielle ne cessent de
distribuer des leçons de morale sur la
liberté et la démocratie mais vous
piétinez ces valeur aujourd'hui avec le
projet de loi sécurisé et régulel
numérique en soutenant l'obligation de
lier l'identité numérique à l'identité
physique c'est-à-dire en supprimant
l'anonyat en ligne vous vous attaquez à
la philosophie même de ce qu'est
Internet
Internet est et doit rester un espace de
liberté en obligeant les Français à
fournir leur document d'identité pour
accéder aux réseaux sociaux vous ferez
d'Internet une parodie de safe space
walk autocensuré sans débat sans
dialogue sans vie cette fin de
l'anonymat que vous préparez est
liberticide mais surtout
inefficace tout simplement parce que la
loi existe et qu'elle est d'ors et déjà
bien faite quand quand une infraction
est constatée il y a une réquisition du
procureur ou une plainte et derrière une
enquête de police puis une condamnation
s'il doit en avoir une le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'effectifs et de moyens pour le recueil
des plaintes et des et les enquêtes en
vérité au lieu de donner plus de moyens
à la police et à la justice vous
préférez vous attaquer aux libertés des
Français pire les amendements de
monsieur le rapporteur Paul midi ne sont
en fait que l'arbre qui cache la forêt
car même si c'est les amendements sont
rejetés l'article 5 de ce texte met lui
aussi en danger l'anonymat en ligne euh
en exigeant des réseaux sociaux qu'ils
empêchent la création d'un compte par un
individu condamné en d'autres termes
vous demandez au réseaux sociaux
d'assumer le flicage des Français à
votre place c'est inacceptable vous avez
perdu
l'esprit enfin les seuls pays qui ont
réussi à bannir l'anonymat sont des
régimes autoritaires comme la Chine
est-ce donc là réellement un modèle dont
vous souhaitez vous
inspirer dernière ligne rouge la
souveraineté numérique et la grande
absente de ce projet de loi comment vous
pouvez-vous prétendre réguler l'espace
numérique si vous entretenez une
dépendance aux multinationales
étrangères ce texte était pourtant le
véhicule parfait pour aborder cet enjeu
de souveraineté numérique et laisser
sénateur l'avait bien compris en
introduisant l'article 10 B a qui
entendait réserver la commande publique
en matière de Cloud à des entreprises
européennes et uniquement
[Musique]
européennes pour le traitement et
l'hébergement des données sensibles le
but de cet article était clair expulser
les gfames de la commande publique et en
passant éjecter Microsoft du Data hub où
sont stocké les données de santé des
Français cela avait deux avantages
évidents d'une part protéger nos données
sensibles pour des raisons de sécurité
nationale et d'indépendance stratégique
d'autre part de développer notre propre
écosystème numérique et de favoriser des
entreprises françaises européennes comme
scalway numspot ou OVH qui sont d'ors et
déjà prêtes à répondre aux appels
d'offre de
l'État c'est cela l'état stratège que
Marine Le Pen ne cesse d'appeler de ses
vœux c'est un état qui utilise la
commande pu public comme un levier non
seulement pour exclure tout risque
d'ingérant sur notre sol mais aussi pour
permettre le développement de notre
propre industrie du numérique dans un
marché étouffé par les
gfames la minorité présidentielle a
trahi notre souveraineté et notre
écosystème numérique en supprimant en
commission cet article vous vous moquez
donc
éperdument de notre souveraineté
numérique et vous avez également une
peur bleue de vous attaer aux intérêts
américains en
Europe alors heureusement il y a tout de
même de bonnes mesures proposé par ce
projet de loi l'interopérabilité et
l'encadrement des crédits cloud qui
permettront aux clients de ne plus être
captif d'un seul
prestataire une meilleure prévention
contre les fraudes en ligne avec le
filtre anti-arnaque et surtout une
meilleure pénalisation des plateformes
qui mettent à disposition des mineurs du
contenu pornographique
mais ça ne suffit pas à faire de ce
texte une bonne loi le groupe
ressemblement national sera extrêmement
vigilant sur la défense de l'anonymat en
ligne et sur la défense de notre
souveraineté numérique vous allez nous
avoir sur votre chemin mais maintenant
place au
débat merci monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame ségolen am pour le coupe la
France insoumise
nupes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
ministres Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs la Chine a réinventé le
contrôle social à l'aair du numérique et
Macron souhaite le sien à la
française ce puissant système chinois
techno sécuritaire vise à noter pister
et juger les habitants du pays et faire
en sorte que chacun se tienne au carreau
sous peine de ne pas pouvoir emprunter
par exemple les transports en
commun un rêve pour Monsieur
Macron et il ne s'en cache plus depuis
l'arrivée du président Macron nos
liberté publique s'effondre peu à peu
les Françaises et les Français se sont
englués dans un filet sécuritaire
dénoncé par les associations jusqu'aux
plus hautes organ organisation
internationale comme l'ONU ce qui nous
vaut le glorioux titre de démocratie
défaillante depuis 6 ans plusieurs
textes de loi penchent du côté de la
sécurité au détriment des libertés la
loi sur la sécurité intérieure avec
l'état d'urgence dans le droit commun la
loi anticasseur privant a priori un
individu de sa liberté de circuler ou de
manifester la nouvelle doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre avec le recours au
NAS retoqué par le Conseil d'État la loi
sur le secret des affaires en 2018
mettant à mal la liberté d'informer la
loi sur la sécurité globale souhaitant
limiter la diffusion d'images de
policiers censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel la vidéosurveillance
algorithmique instauré par le PGL enfin
par le la loi sur les jeux olympiques
2024 et la loi de programmation de la
justice permettant d'orénavant d'activer
à distance les caméras et les micros de
vos téléphones
portables bienvenue en
macronistant ce contrôle de la de la vie
physique est réel et souhaite trouver
son modèle pour nos vies numériques
l'influence chinoise semble avoir porté
ses fruits jusqu'à l'Élysée dans les
politiques liberticides et autoritaires
porté par la macronie vous l'aurez
compris ce texte ne nous convient
absolument pas si nous pouvons nous
accorder sur le constat de l'existence
de violence et d'abus sur Internet
reflet virtuel de ce qui se passe dans
nos vies physiques nous ne pouvons que
nous opposer à la réponse que vous y
apportez ce texte est mensongé et laisse
croire que le recours à des solutions
techniques permettrait de protéger les
mineurs et les les utilisateurs
d'Internet de façon générale la solution
technique que vous vendez à Touva est un
leur abandonné par l'Australie par le
Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis elle crée
un sentiment contre-productif de
protection mais est toujours
contournable
nous ne cessons de le répéter il
n'existe actuellement aucune solution
technique qui permette la vérification
de l'âge qui soit compatible avec le
droit au respect de la vie privée et le
droit de l'anonymat sur Internet même
l'arcom l'a récemment avoué en audition
et le référentiel ne sera pas applicable
à court terme ce texte est hypocrite
toutes ces dispositions visant à
protéger les mineurs sur sur Internet
mettent en lumière l'abandon du
gouvernement
en terme de politique d'éducation et de
prévention qui sont pourtant les
premières armes à mobiliser surtout les
plus efficaces beaucoup d'élèves
traversent aujourd'hui leur scolarité
sans avoir bénéficié d'une seule séance
d'éducation à la sexualité le 2 mars
2023 c'est le planning familial s
d'action et SOS Homophobie qui ont saisi
le tribunal administratif à Paris pour
que la loi de 2001 soit enfin appliqué
hypocrite toujours quand la police
judiciaire et la gendarmerie ne dispose
pas des moyens suffisants pour lutter
efficacement contre la
pédocriminalité les moyens de la justice
face au géant du numérique ont toujours
été trop faibles et face à ce constat
d'échec nous ne remettons pas en
question votre politique budgétaire et
vous choisissez tout simplement de
contourner le juge judiciaire en passant
par les autorités
administratives après la loi avia en
grande partie censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel ce projet de loi
persiste dans absence d'intervention du
juge et propose donc la seule
qualification de l'infraction par
l'administration cela va dans le sens de
l'accroissement des pouvoirs
administratifs au détriment du pouvoir
judiciaire laissant à l'exécutif des
pouvoirs toujours plus grands et mettant
à mal la séparation des
pouvoirs Montesquieu l'un des pères de
la séparation des pouvoirs écrivait que
l'oppression commence toujours par le
sommeil vous ne faites là qu'endormir
les Françaises et les Français et nous
serons toujours présents pour l'en
empêcher dans la rue comme dans cet
hémicycle ce projet de loi est une boîte
de pendor social et sécuritaire dont
certains états totalitaires pourraient
se vanter nous ne sommes plus dans un
roman dystopique mais bien dans la
réalité comptez sur nous pour mettre un
frein pour mettre un frein radical à ces
réformes toujours plus liberticides et
autoritaires afin d'éviter la création
d'outils dont nous ne sommes toujours
pas en mesure de prédire les
conséquences bravo merci madame la
députée la parole est à Monsieur Victor
aberbert d'assau pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
merci
Madame madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre chers
collègues le projet de loi sur l'espace
numérique apparaît comme un sujet
complexe technique qui façonne notre
époque et notre avenir la régulation du
monde numérique l'aire de la
digitalisation est un changement majeur
qui bouleverse nos usages notre économie
et notre façon d'appréhender les
relations humaines c'est av être cette
conviction profondément ancrée que
j'avais proposé de créer une commission
permanente du numérique au côté des
autres commissions pour venir en appui
et aiguiller le travail réalisé au sein
de celle-ci un travail régulier et
exhaustif serait alors permis en étroite
relation avec le Parlement européen et
la Commission des Affaires européennes
en un mot une commission spéciale
temporaire ne paraît pas être suffisante
au regard des enjeux auxquels nous
sommes confrontés le Parlement doit
s'emparer du numérique comme un sujet à
part entière et pas comme une variable
d'ajustement le présent projet de loi
récemment examiné par le Sénat témoigne
de notre engagement à offrir à notre
pays une législation à la hauteur de ce
que le monde numérique nous promet de
meilleurs mais là où croi ce qui sauve
croit aussi le péril de la liberté de la
créativité de la facilité des échanges
il expose aussi les utilisateurs aux
usages les plus sombres à l'insécurité à
la violence de la vie privée ou au
harcèlement voire à l'injustice le
grouple républicain a d'ailleurs été au
cœur de cette transformation législative
avec une vision stratégique et un sens
des responsabilités je tiens ici à
rendre hommage en particulier au travail
des sénateurs Patrick chaise et loï
Hervé c'est à la République de reprendre
la main en protégeant nos con citoyens
et en anticipant le comportement les
plus à risque je pense comme vous chers
collègues à nos jeunes parfois perdus et
esselés derrière leur écran à nos aînés
aux populations les plus fragiles
confrontés au vendeurs d'amour au SMS au
mail frauduleux visant à usurper une
identité un numéro de carte bleue les
coordonnées de cartes bancaires voire de
la sécurité sociale le filtre
anti-arnaac en ce sens apparaît comme un
filtre de protection indispensable la
vigilance et l'adaptabilité sont nos
maîtres mots ce texte est une nécessité
notamment pour la protection des mineurs
face aux sirènes de l'industrie
pornographique mais si l'objet est plus
que légitime les défis techniques seront
nombreux et les exemples dans d'autres
pays doivent nous contraindre à une
vigilance accrue et à des efforts
redoublés nous resterons attentifs
également au cadre de référence mis en
place par l'arcom ainsi qu'à son
utilisation sur l'article 15 et la et la
régulation des jeux numériques à objets
monétisable le groupe les républi
insiste sur le soutien aux nouvelles
technologies et à l'innovation mais tout
en anticipant les risques associés en
proposant donc de restreindre la portée
de cet article de l'expérimentation aux
jeux de fantaisie sportive et épique il
ne faut pas que cette nouvelle
réglementation servent d'appel d'air à
des acteurs qui chercheraient par tout
moyen à contourner les règles existences
et un premier bilan sera évidemment
nécessaire quant à l'article 10 B a voté
au Sénat mais supprimé en commission
spéciale nous proposons de le
réintroduire en partie mais en tenant
compte des défis auquels les
fournisseurs de stockage de données
entreprises et administration pourrai
être confronté cette réintroduction vise
ainsi à fixer un cap pour renforcer la
protection collective des données
sensibles contre les risques liés aux
législations étrangère nous pouvons
également souligner le rôle majeur dans
ce texte qui sera que sera amené à jouer
l'arcom comme le précise l'article 25
l'arcom laacnil et et la DGCCRF sont
considérés comme les autorités nationale
pour la mise en œuvre du DSA et nous
pouvons saluer le rôle de coordinateur
de l'arcom dans ce trio toutefois nous
veillerons à ce que l'impératif
d'indépendance de ces autorités comme le
soune le DSA soit respecté ce qui n'est
à priori pas tout à fait le cas de la
DGCCRF relié à B cela pose un problème
de conformité au droit européens le
groupe les républicains plaide pour une
régulation équilibrée innovante et
sécurisé garantissant à la France une
souveraineté numérique car derrière
cette notion de souveraineté c'est la
question de la protection de No valeurs
et de notre modèle démocratique qui est
en jeu les événements tragiques de la
fin juin ont d'ailleurs rappelé avec une
acuité brutale combien les réseaux
sociaux peuvent agir comme une poudrière
le flot constant de messages d'images ou
de vidéos transmis à la vitesse écla
amplifié et à démultiplier les violences
comme si le pire était toujours certain
face à cette nouvelle menace numérique
nous demandons la capacité à nos
autorités d'intervenir plus efficacement
contre les menaces d'atteintte aux biens
et aux personnes dans le strict respect
des droits et des libertés notre mission
chers collègues est de façonner une
législation qui protège nos citoyens
tout en favorisant l'innovation cette
dualité est le reflet de notre
engagement une France qui embrasse son
avenir numérique avec ambition et
confiance tout en affirmant fermement
qu'il faut un ou plusieurs gardiens dans
le temple numérique le changement donc
dans la fidélité à nos valeurs avec
cette législation et nous l'espérons
avec nos propositions nous allons faire
un pas de plus vers une France Numérique
plus forte plus souveraine et plus
protectrice pour ces raisons et si après
les sénateurs les députés les réublains
sont entendus nous voterons en faveur de
ce texte nous avons une responsabilité
collective de veiller à ce que le
numérique soit à la fois un moteur de
progrès et un espace
d'épanouissement merci monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Erwan
balanan pour le groupe démocrate modem
et
indépendant monsieur le ministre madame
la Présidente mesames et Messieurs les
les rapporteurs chers collègues lors de
nos travaux préparatoires sur ce projet
de Jo de loi pardon
euh qui était très joyeux aussi euh je
je vous cache pas mon mon étonnement
face à la satisfaction exprimée par
certains acteurs du numérique à les
écouter nous pourrions croire que
l'espace numérique était sain sécurisé
et que tout allait bien dans le meilleur
des mondes
certains
considèrent certains opérateurs
considèrent déjà avoir mis en œuvre les
outils de régulation et de contrôle pour
protéger leurs utilisateurs alors s'il
faut pager leurs efforts puisque depuis
quelques années ils font effectivement
des efforts je crois que il reste
beaucoup à faire et nous ne pouvons pas
nous contenter de leurs petites avancées
d'ailleurs je vous rappelle un des
nombreux drames d'Internet et de ces
réseaux c'est la plainte déposer contre
TikTok pour provocation au suicide non
non assistance à personne en péril et
propagande ou publicité des moyens de se
donner la mort par les parents d'une
d'une jeune femme d'une fille qui
s'était suicidée en septembre 2021 alors
si cette plainte ne vise effectivement
qu'une plateforme elle nous rappelle que
toutes les plateformes ont effectivement
un rôle à jouer et toutes doivent
comprendre leurs responsabilité qu'elles
ont dans la l'écosystème qu'elle qu'elle
crée et la nécessité pour elle de
maîtriser les risques relatifs aux
usages d'Internet alors le groupe
nbocrate ne peut donc que saluer
monsieur le ministre l'arrivée de ce
projet de loi dans notre hémicycle
saluer aussi votre travail votre
détermination à faire de ce texte un
texte qui protège nos enfants mais qui
protège aussi les adultes et qui protège
aussi les entreprise alors nous nous
apprêtons à à discuter d'un projet de
loi qui répond au aux enjeux de setion
des internautes et je l'ai dit à
commencé par nos enfants pour eux il
nous est urgent d'assaignir cet
écosystème numérique lors des auditions
puis du travail en commission nous avons
eu à cœur de doter l'état d'outils
pertinent efficace non seulement pour
punir mais aussi pour que chacun en
bonne intelligence puisse utiliser ce
formidable outil d'manticipation
d'information et d'innovation qui est le
numérique et je remercie à cette
occasion les rapporteurs pour leur
travail ainsi que l'aide précieuse
apportée par les
administrateurs
collectivement collectivement nous avons
travaillé pour trouver des compromis
sans les iner sur un principe celui de
la responsabilité j'aime rappeler un
concept que nous devrions décliner
d'ailleurs dans bon nombre de domaines
c'est le concept du pollueur payeur
aujourd'hui et dans cette logique force
de constater que certains acteurs ne
jouent pas encore pleinement leur rôle
de réparation de l'écosystème que leurs
algorithmes et leur système pollu en
quelque sorte alors l'impunité ne peut
exister sous aucun prétexte nous avons
trop d'exemples en tête pour illustrer
le déferlement de haine et les
conséquences souvent dramatiques de ces
comportements s'il faut reconnaître que
les acteurs du numérique ne peuvent
porter à eux seuls les responsabilités
des violences diffusées sur leur site au
même titre que l'État elles doivent à
minima mettre en place des solutions
pérennes de modération et de régulation
des contenus en ligne alors alors pour
cela nous devons aussi nous législateurs
définir des interdits clairs et précis
et dans ce sens la délectualisation de
l'outrage sexiste et sexuel lorsqu'il
est commis en ligne en éteint le recours
à l'amende forfaitaire délictuelle
permettra alors de réprimer plus
efficacement plus rapidement ses
outrages dans dans l'espace public
numérique toutefois la FD l'amende
forfaitaire délictuelle ne peut être la
réponse à tous les cyber outrages nous
devons nous garder de créer un délit
d'outrage puni d'une telle amende qui
reste qui risquerait d'englober des
infractions plus graves plus sévèrement
réprimées et pour lesquelles il est
nécessaire de laisser le temps à la
justice de faire son travail alors nous
devons aussi prévoir des sanctions à la
hauteur de l'interdit la peine
complémentaire d'interdiction et de
suspension d'accès au comptes ayant été
utilisé pour commettre des infractions
est une véritable avancée et je salue je
vous salue madame la rapporteur Louise
Morel pour votre travail sur le sujet et
l'écoute qui a été la vôtre durant ce
texte grâce aux recommandations du
groupe de travail sur les réseaux
sociaux et les violences elle pourra
aussi être prononcée en cas de
provocation directe et publique à
commettre certaines infractions graves
d'atteinte aux personnes et aux biens
enfin pour conclure nous devons assurer
que le développement en France de
l'économie des objets de jeu numérique
monétisable se fera dans un cadre
protecteur et je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui
il n'existe rien donc si nous ne faisons
rien nous ouvrons la porte à toutes les
dérives si nous soutenons une telle
expérimentation nous serons le groupe
démocrate est extrêmement attentif à ce
que la protection des mineurs face à ces
jeux prime sur le reste en tout état de
cause le groupe démocrate votera ce
texte indispensable pour sécuriser et
réguler notre espace numérique et
assurer la souveraineté de la France en
la matière je vous remercie merci
monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Hervé
Solignac pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur
général peut-on raisonnablement
prétendre réguler l'espace numérique la
question me semble-t-il se pose tant il
est vrai que cet espace semble se
développer en échappant à toutes les
règles toutes les lois et même parfois
les notions les plus élémentaires de la
morale la technologie avance ses pions
le politique lui court après sans
parvenir à combler son retard depuis 6
an les textes régulateurs se sont
multipliés au point de constituer un
millefeuille un peu indigeste disons-le
et surtout impuissant la preuve de cette
impuissance ce sont les 150000 requêtes
annuelles adressées à Faros qui donnent
lieu à une cinquantaine de poursuitite
judiciaire seulement autant dire que
c'est l'impunité qui triomphe alors le
chemin est étroit entre ceux qui
considèrent que toute régulation est
attentatoire aux libertés et ceux qui
considèrent qu'on peut bien sacrifier
quelques libertés fond ental pour
combattre les délinquants de la toile
évidemment une petite dose de mesures
liberticide serait très efficace mais
liberticide une grande dose de respect
de nos libertés fondamentales serait
vertueusees mais relativement inefficace
c'est ainsi Monsieur le Ministre que
vous naviguer dans le Triangle des
Bermudes entre les lignes rouges de
l'Europe les limites de notre
Constitution et les attachements divers
que nous portons les uns et les autres à
l'endroit de nos libertés publiques et
individuelles alors d'abord vous nous
soumettez un dispositif pour lutter
contre l'accès des mineurs au sititees
pornographique monsieur le ministre vous
nous aurez toujours à vos côtés dans ce
combat d'autant que jusqu'à présent les
plateformes se moquent ouvertement du
législateur et considèrent qu'elles ont
fait leur travail en faisant cocher la
case je suis majeur à ce stade je ne
peux pas affirmer avec certitude que vos
résultats seront bien meilleurs que ceux
de vos prédécesseurs désormais les
plateformes devront se conformer à un
référentiel que vous nous avez présenté
comme une sorte de boîte à outils or
pour le moment la boîte à outil
ressemble plutôt à une boîte noire dès
lors que le référentiel n'a pas été
élaboré vous nous demandez en effet
d'approuver un objet juridique qui
n'existe pas ce qui est plus préoccupant
c'est que personne ne semble tout à fait
d'accord sur ce que doit contenir ce
référentiel l'arcom auditionné encore
récemment peine à masquer ses doutes sur
la mission qui lui est assigné monsieur
le ministre vous le savez les
plateformes n'ont aucune intention de se
conformer à un cadre légal elles
chercheront par tout moyen à contourner
ce nouveau cadre elles utiliseront
toutes les faiblesses du référentiel
tous les recours juridique il convient
de les bloquer et de les soumettre à des
sanctions financières très lourdes quand
elles s'exonéreront de leurs obligations
en tout état de cause tant que 2
millions et demi de mineurs visiteront
chaque mois un site pornographique on
légiférera à vide permettez-moi
maintenant de m'attarder un instant sur
un objet non identifié pour ne pas dire
un cavalier dans ce texte les jeunumes
monsieur le ministre puisque vous voulez
réguler les jaunumes aller jusqu'au bout
de la démarche et traiter de la question
des jeux illégaux en ligne le jeu
illégal en ligne c'est entre 2 et 3
milliards de chiffres par an soit à peu
près l'équivalent du chiffre de tous les
casinos terrestre français ces montants
colossaux profitent profitent à des
paradis fiscaux ne donnent lieu à aucune
retombée nationale et la France offre
une drôle d'image quand elle officialise
les jeunumes mais refuse de se doter
d'une législ d'une législation sur les
jeux en ligne vous laissez ainsi filer
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
de recettes fiscales vous autoriser le
développement des jeunumes sans cadre
précis ni agrément nécessairire au seul
motif que la France pourrait être
pionnière alors si vous ne savez pas
vraiment définir les junumes je vais
vous en donner ma propre définition ça
s'appelle pour moi tout simplement un
marché avec des cotations qui fluctueent
des actes de vente et d'achat qui
génèent des profits parfois étonnants et
à travers l'article le 15 vous
reconnaissez implicitement ce marché
mais vous ne l'encadrez pas vraiment et
vous vous trouvez quelque part un peu en
contradiction avec l'intitulé même de
votre projet de loi enfin nous alertons
le gouvernement sur le fait que si les
nouveaux pouvoirs des administrations et
des régulateurs je pense ici à l'arcom
notamment ne s'accompagne pas de moyens
supplémentaires alors les dispositions
du projet de loi resteront lettres
mortte à cet égard je rappelle que le
PLF de 2024 prévoit seulement 10
équivalent en plein de plus pour l'arcom
pas de quoi procéder au contrôle et aux
injonctions qui se profil vous l'aurez
compris monsieur le ministre nous
reconnaissons des avancées intéressantes
dans ce texte la recherche aussi d'un
certain équilibre qui tranche avec
d'autres textes dans le passé qui ont
été largement censurés par le Conseil
constitutionnel mais également encore
beaucoup d'interrogations qui demeurent
et qui feront je n'en doute pas tout le
sel de nos débats je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame agès Carel pour le groupe horizon
et
[Applaudissements]
apparenté merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la commission spéciale
monsieur le rapporteur général Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs thématique
mes chers
collègues sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique voici les deux objectifs
ambitieux que ce projet de loi s'est
fixé dans ce nouveau champ de liberté la
la loi doit protéger en particulier les
plus vulnérables et c'est notre rôle
aujourd'hui en examinant ce texte
important de trouver les solutions
pertinentes et équilibrées pour répondre
aux enjeux des avancées numériques mais
dans cet espace sans frontières l'action
du législateur français seul placerait
la France dans une situation isolée
voire impuissante s'il en fallait une de
plus l'action conjointe des États
membres en la matière est une preuve
qu'au-delà du symbole d'unité des
peuples l'Union européenne sait donner
les moyens de sa souveraineté et de sa
compétitivité à ce titre le groupe
horizon et apparenté salue l'adoption
des différents règlements européens en
partie transposé au sein de ce projet de
loi le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui rulte d'un long travail de
nos collègues sénateurs mais également
des membres de la commission spéciale je
salue à cette occasion le président Luc
lamirot le rapporteur général Paul midi
et les rapporteurs thématiques notamment
ma collègue horizon Anne
leenanf nous avons auditionné de très
nombreux spécialistes et organismes
associations entreprises acteurs du
numérique qui nous ont permis d'avancer
et de mieux comprendre les enjeux de ce
texte et de faire évoluer certains
aspects par le biais de nombreux
amendements votés en commission
construire un ordre public numérique est
une nécessité le groupe horizon en a
pris pleinement la mesure nous avons
souhaiter dès notre première niche
parlementaire poser les jalons d'une
protection efficace des mineurs contre
les externalités hélas négatives et
avéré des réseaux sociaux pour les plus
jeunes dans la lignée des
recommandations du DSA c'était la
profonde conviction de notre président
de groupe et de ses membres nous sommes
heureux qu'elle ait trouvé un écho
positif puisque elle a
voté à l'unanimité dans les deux
chambres la loi marcangé vise également
à redonner le pouvoir aux parents pour
qu'ils puissent jouer pleinement leur
rôle de contrôle n'oublions pas que
l'efficacité de toutes ces dispositions
tient aussi et surtout en un mot
l'éducation nous ne sécuriserons
véritablement l'espace numérique que si
chacun d'entre nous est véritablement
formé aux opportunités et au risques que
ce nouvel espace virtuel présente cet
enjeu a pu trouver une place dans le
présent projet de loi et nous avons
déposé plusieurs amendements visant à
lui donner une place encore plus
importante sa juste place ce projet de
loi comporte en outre un arsenal
important que nous soutenons protéger
d'abord et avant tout les mineurs face à
l'exposition toujours plus importante
aux images pornographique protéger nos
concitoyens contre les actes
malveillants qu'il s'agisse de
cyberhcèlement ou d'arnaque en ligne
protéger nos entreprises et nos
collectivités en posant les bases d'une
souveraineté économique et numérique au
sein de l'Union européenne il ambitionne
également de réguler et encadrer les
jeunes hommes jeunum dont la situation
résume résume bien la difficulté dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons le numérique
va beaucoup plus loin beaucoup plus vite
que nous et nous ne savons pas de quoi
demain sera fait alors comment réguler
correctement de manière équilibrée pour
soutenir l'innovation sans renier nos
principes structurant je crois à ce
titre que la rédaction de l'article 15
bis en commission trouve cette cet
équilibre intelligent nous souhaitons
tout de même que la protection des
mineurs soit davantage assurée c'est le
sens des amendements que nous avons
déposé enfin si ce projet de loi a été
l'occasion de souligner le nouveau champ
de risque et de danger que le numérique
a ouvert n'oublions pas de rappeler
l'immense opportunité qu'il constitue
une opportunité de simplification
notamment des rapport parfois laborieux
avec l'administration l'identification
unique proposée par France Connect plus
est déjà une grande avancée et la France
se positionne en leader sur l'identité
numérique régalienne aujourd'hui
développée par France identité le groupe
horizon et apparenté souhaite aller plus
loin en proposant une expérimentation
permettant à nos concitoyens d'accéder
de manière sécurisée à une plateforme
unique rassemblant l'ensemble des
services publics impôts démarches
d'Assurance Maladie d'allocation
familiale procuration de vote
inscription à l'école ou à la crèche et
j'en passe autant de démarches qui sont
aujourd'hui effectu
sur différents sites au sein de
différents organismes qui communiquent
parfois mal entre eux nous sommes
convaincus que le numérique constiue à
ce titre une chance inouï dont il faut
que nous nous saisissions vous l'aurez
compris le groupe Horizon est apparenté
profondément convaincu de la nécessité
de construire ce nouvel ordre public
numérique votera en faveur de ce projet
de loi je vous remercie merci madame la
députée la parole est à Madame emmanu
Ménard en tant que députée non
[Applaudissements]
inscrite
prés madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues Chac année 136 milliards de
vidéos pornographiques sont visionné
dans le monde en France un mineur sur 3
soit 2,3 millions d'enfants regardent du
porno au moins une fois par mois pendant
plus de 50 minutes une proportion à
peine plus faible que chez les adultes
qui sont 37 % à en consommer ce n'est
pas tout depuis 2017 le nombre de
mineurs qui consomment du porno ne cesse
d'augmenter plus 600000 en 5 ans et leur
profil est de plus en plus jeune 51 %
des garçons de 12- 13 ans regardent des
sites pornographiques chaque mois et 21
% des garçons de 10-1 ans des chiffres
glaçants car derrière eux c'est la santé
mentale sociale sexuel et même la
capacité à aimer de nos enfants qui sont
profondément abîmés des dégâts qui
risquent d'être de plus en plus
important puisque actuellement 90 % des
vidéos en ligne contiennent des
violences verbal physique et sexuelle
quand ce ne sont pas des actes de
barbarie des viols ou des incitations à
l'inceste pour protéger nos enfants de
la pornographie le gouvernement a choisi
l'Autorité de régulation de la
communication audiovisuelle et numérique
l'arcom son pouvoir ordonner sans
décision judiciaire le blocage des sites
pornographiques qui ne vérifient pas
l'âge de leur visiteurs pour plus
d'efficacité nous dites-vous nous
devrions donc être rassurés satisfaits
même et pourtant ce n'est ni plus ni
moins que le juge gardien de notre droit
et de nos libertés qui est mis sur le
banc de touche par le gouvernement
quelle claque quelle irresponsabilité
aussi car en le contournant ce sont ces
prérogatives que nous allons
sous-traiter triste aveu d'impuissance
de l'État qui se refuse ainsi à donner
de véritables moyens à notre justice
pour accomplir ses missions vous
préférez les confier à un autre assez
peu efficace il faut bien l'avouer
puisque depuis 2020 moins de 10 sites
ont été mis en demeure par l'arcom sans
résultats concrets pour ma part je crois
urgent de lutter concrètement contre la
pornographie chez les mineurs et pour
cela la première mesure devrait être de
rendre payant l'ensemble des sites et
plateformes délivrant des contenus
pornographiques une mesure simple
doublée d'une fermeture automatique dès
lors que cette condition n'est pas
respecté les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet qui ne fermeraient pas les
sites gratuits et les plateformes et
sites qui diffuse librement du porno
serait donc immédiatement sanctionné
bref il faut se donner les moyens d'agir
car il y a urgence pour nos enfants
l'urgence ne doit cependant pas servir
de prétexte à l'acceptation insidieuse
d'une identité numérique qui Infiné
pourrait permettre de contrôler chacun
d'entre nous sur internet le
gouvernement souhaite d'ailleurs que 80
% des Français soient détenteurs d'une
identité numérique d'ici 2027 et près de
100 % à l'horizon 2030 des objectifs
inquiétants si cette identité numérique
administrative n'est pas clairement
dissociée de l'identité numérique qui
nous est attribuée au quotidien pour
naviguer sur la toile car si aujourd'hui
la cible est la pornographie pourquoi de
pourquoi pas demain s'attaquer à
l'alcool ou à ou à l'accès aux cours en
ligne tout aussi inquiétant la liberté
d'expression semble être attaquée avec
le retour si l'on peut dire de la loi
avia dans l'article 5 un retour qui
interroge puisque qu'elle avait été je
vous le rappelle quasiment intégralement
censurée par le Conseil constitutionnel
en juin 2020 chasser la censure elle
revient au Galot une censure qui
pourrait se manifester par la création
d'une peine complémentaire visant à
bannir des réseaux sociaux entre 6 mois
et 1 an une personne condamnée pour
certains délits alors si je partage
naturellement avec vous la volonté de
neutraliser les internautes condamné
pour pédopornographie
proxénétisme apologie du terrorisme ou
harcèlement sex
je m'interroge sur les éventuelles
manipulations de l'information dont vous
parlez et qui ne sont pas clairement
identifié mais qui pourrait être censuré
autant de danger que ce texte Fourtout
ne parvient pas à neutraliser et qui
interroge